so
tomorrow's a big day joe biden and
kamala harris will be inaugurated they
will become
president and vice president donald
trump will leave
and for some reason no one's allowed to
be there there's 25
000 national guard occupying dc
and journalists seem to love the idea of
25 000 troops
occupying washington dc we had a guest
on i think it was uh
whether they say it's double the amount
of troops we have over in afghanistan
something like that
or maybe even more than that like 10
times what was it was like yeah
we have like 2 500 in afghanistan we
have like 10 times the amount of troops
in dc right now and you know the left
and the right both
think something weird is going to happen
now i i've i've heard the craziest
conspiracy theories on the right and
honestly i just think
joe biden is going to walk in he's going
to hold up his hand say some words and
then we're going to move on
then i'll issue some executive orders
everybody will get mad and then we'll be
back to bickering about politics but i
do think there's still a risk of serious
escalation
because joe biden is going to be doing
hard reversals on tons of trump's
executive orders
which is a 180 degree turn which means
that's a hard swing in the other
direction which is going to freak people
out
on the left however they're seriously
concerned about some right-wing militia
you know protest or insurgency or
whatever
and as far as i know i believe it's 30
states so far have activated the
national guard
the big news right now is that so far 12
guards
have been removed because after being
vetted
turns out some of them i guess are
retweeting things they don't like or
associate with the nra that's one report
coming from jack bosobic
what we can say is they've been removed
many people have likened this to failing
a loyalty test
so it's kind of weird it's kind of weird
that democrats and
the establishment are that concerned
they've issued two to now
statements one letter to soldiers saying
do not support trump
another op-ed saying if you do you will
be arrested and prosecuted
and now they're going through all the
history of these people that's getting
crazy
we have a very excellent guest tonight
however probably uh one of the experts
on
probably uh survival camps well i'll
i'll just throw two cause i don't wanna
i don't wanna downplay
um your credentials this is uh steve
renee ceo of fortitude ranch do you
wanna just explain
who you are what you do yeah so my
name's uh steve renee i'm the ceo
of fortitude ranch and the operations
manager for
fortitude ranch west virginia we we are
a recreational slash
survivalist community
we started in colorado over seven years
ago
the founder dr drew miller began the
first ranch then he bought the property
out
in west virginia and then once that was
got to the point of being up and running
then he hired me i came on in
to run the operations and then we this
year we've expanded into
nevada for a third ranch and
we're going to continue to grow and grow
are these like these are underground
underground bunkers we have we have
hardened facilities but no
it's it's not all underground we have
everything from
beautiful log homes to hardened shelters
it's uh there's a mixture you have a big
beautiful wall surrounding the property
uh we don't we're
we don't appear to be militaristic
because we are not militaristic
we fit in in any community that you
would
if you drove by the facility in west
virginia you'd never know
the the building you would first see
used to actually be a bed and breakfast
oh wow yeah a it's a gorgeous log home
that's comfortable and that's where the
luxury memberships are located then as
you get back further into
uh the compound itself i don't even like
to use the word compound that's why we
use
ranch we keep ourselves away from
you know anything tied to militias
we're about defending our own
and when that time comes and until that
time comes then
members are able to come to the ranch
and relax and
so yeah the big news came i think was
october you guys activated ahead of the
election
and that kind of got people worried i
know we talked about it quite a bit
that you were basically telling people
come on down to the ranch
in case there's you know mass unrest or
some kind of catastrophe yeah and we try
we try to stay ahead of what's coming
in obviously we're not nostradamus in
any sort of way but he wasn't that good
anyway right but the point is you know
so
we stay out of politics but we have to
monitor politics so that we can
you know get the idea of what's coming
and
help our members to be prepared for that
and of course they always have questions
and so this is anything could be like a
natural disaster
civil unrest political yeah we're we are
built to be able to
sustain a nuclear uh shockwave
wow so aside from that you're also uh
former army intelligence
i was i was five years in nukes and i
was five years in
military intelligence we were hearing
some pretty crazy stories
just before we went live so i'm like
wait stop talking like we gotta this is
crazy stuff we should definitely talk
about on the show so
we'll get in all this and we'll talk
about fortitude ranch and uh
it's a survival and recreation camp i
guess you call it yeah cool
uh so we also have as always luke caskey
oh hi
hi guys hello hi how you doing just
stretching over here oh
oh wow another we are change exclusive
t-shirt tonight which you could only
get on we are change.org ford
shirts who are just a random coincidence
thank you so much for having me on and
you brought up a very
good important point if you're bugging
out you don't want to tell
the world that you're bugging out also
it would be interesting to talk about
your military experience especially when
it comes to the military vetting that's
going on but
we have a lot to get into so i'm really
excited i'm very happy that you're on
appreciate it and i'm ian crossland
hello luke is actually a bigger hippie
than i am even though i look
more like a hippie i think um it's cool
here see because we were just talking
about atlantis yesterday
and i don't know if you know about the
asteroid impact 28 000 years ago that
purportedly
ended the last ice age uh shattered over
north america peppered the glaciers and
then caused a global flood
that wiped out an entire civilization um
and multiple
businesses is that real like that this
is what the evidence points to right but
i'm wondering
would you could you handle an asteroid
impact well nothing can handle an
asteroid impact
i mean we couldn't handle a nuclear
blast if you're ground zero
nothing lasts ground zero so the point
is not to be where that's heading
and then have the proper facilities uh
to make sure that the shock wave
doesn't do the damage could you survive
underwater if there was a flood for a
short period of time or something
yeah we we're surrounded by mountains
you just go up wow
that's cool yeah all right well the
first portion
we'll talk about the political strife
but we actually do have like the cia
released the ufo documents
and so we'll get into the more weird and
wild asteroids and it'll be fun to talk
to you about the more you know
i don't know i don't want to say
conspiratorial but paranormal
aspects of the survival stuff that's
probably not the right way to put it
like an asteroid impact or aliens or
whatever
uh if we're just jumping into the
stories we started off with that
story about soldiers being vetted from
your military experience i don't i hope
you don't mind if we were just jumping
into it
not yet okay all right there's one more
person there's another human being oh
yes
how rude of me i'm so sorry i'm here in
the corner it looks like luke likes to
try to jump into things but
i'm really excited to have this guest
because i was psyched to learn about
fortitude ranch and i'm stoked to learn
about
all the details tonight yeah yeah it'll
be interesting context too especially
with your military experience
everything's going on which is what luke
mentioned but uh before we do that luke
who wants to promote his shirts
go to timcast.com become a member and
get access to exclusive content because
we actually now have two segments we
just launched the site last week we're
still working out bugs
there's also a shop and if you go to
timcast.com and click that shop button
you can buy your exclusive i am a
gorilla t-shirt which apparently is the
most popular shirt we've ever made
and it's not even political i don't get
it but everybody loves the grill shirt
it's funny and now we have we have
gorillas
here for some reason because people just
keep posting gorilla emojis and that's
become the thing thanks alex that's
well we've made money on the shirts i'll
put it that way but go to teamcast.com
become a member
and don't forget to like subscribe hit
the notification bell and share this uh
podcast right now if you really do like
it you really want to help us grow
sharing word of mouth the most powerful
way
to uh to help us out but uh let's jump
into that uh that first story
nbc news reports 12 national guard
members removed from inauguration duty
including two for inappropriate comments
the fbi has been screening
all service members involved for the
inauguration amid growing security
concerns
they say quote we have two individuals
that were identified
as making inappropriate comments or
texts
i gotta stop and ask like what is it
what does that mean did they did they
make they post a meme of hillary clinton
or something and all sudden they're
getting
kicked out well it's also stuff that
they retweeted that
supposedly is is is bad content but
we're again getting very generalized
language
no exact examples and we should at least
get that with the latest news and again
it's 12 out of
25 000. it's not a whole lot but it is
kind of weird they're doing it yeah i
got to be honest
so actually i have a twitter thread from
jack posobik he says
white house source the nra turning point
usa
and patriot guard writers are three of
many non-militia groups on the list
cid and fbi are using a cross-reference
in vetting for potential extremists
why yeah what is that young americans
for freedom yep also on the list quote
they're looking at various tp turning
point usa chapters
in almost every university and high
school where there is one for example
high school members who are in the
future soldiers program
which is army's version of delayed entry
program college age soldiers obviously
already in
investigators also looking for the
following in pictures
maga cag apparel gadsden flag
confederate flag nra gear and q stuff i
can understand some of that but the
gadsden flag
i mean at any rate it's all free speech
soldiers facebooks twitters twitter
instagram
tick tocks and snapchats are also being
checked units from deep red states such
as texas being thoroughly examined
left-wing anarchist groups also listed
but not a top priority
in fact zero have been investigated as
of this evening leaders in both the army
and the fbi
have directed to focus attention on
groups with strong conservative
sentiments
ncis afosi cgis also expected to receive
that directive from senior dod officials
in the coming days
this goes way beyond the inauguration it
won't magically stop
after tomorrow so this is actually kind
of freaky
seeing this because you've got democrats
concerned that someone what has a
gadsden flag
and so they're going to investigate
people and remove them from their
mission if that's the case
are we really at the point where you
know we had we had chris cuomo on cnn
say we can't trust our military i mean
i see stuff like that and i think of two
words
you know what those two words are guys
looks got a smile on his face
i was going to say fish sticks i don't
want to get i don't want to get to iran
you know i don't i don't like those
words but uh i've been talking about it
uh for some time and it started when as
i mentioned always
i was reading and i think it was like
new york mag or the atlantic they did uh
so uh
for you steve i'll give you the context
there was an article where they
interviewed a bunch of national security
experts
from various major security companies
and asked them what
what percentage likelihood they thought
it you know we
we had for a potential civil war and
they said in the next 10 years like the
average i think was like 35 or or higher
some people said 95
chance and then watching the escalation
of the culture war and
escalation of politics to this point
where we had a bunch of trump supporters
you know storm through the front doors
of the capitol building
i mean there have been people every step
of the way we've seen some some kind of
escalation they've said no
no no no of course not well now we had a
retired army general i believe army
saying that we've not had this much
security at an inauguration since
abraham lincoln
so it really does feel like we are
knocking on the door for some kind of
major catastrophe now that being said
it doesn't mean it's true everything
could stop right now tomorrow could go
off without a hitch and then everyone
has to slow down and calm down
i just don't see anything happening betw
with the rhetoric from politicians from
high profile personalities
that would indicate things are going to
calm down i mean you got aoc you've got
these leftist corey bush saying expel
the insurrectionist republicans
and so it feels like it's we're boiling
over and we're getting that point
now there's two but before i i want to
ask you this steve
your business thrives when there's when
there's chaos and i mean with all due
respect like when the news is bad
people are going to start thinking about
what they have to do to survive
so you know with that in mind i imagine
you've been tracking a lot of this stuff
you're paying attention to politics to
know what might happen what people might
do and i'd be interested to get your
thoughts on on all of this and what you
think it means
well partly what we're seeing happening
with so much of the military presence is
because it's so fresh
so there's always an overreaction
especially when you look in the
political arena because everybody one
has to
cover themselves politically and then
you know two this really hasn't happened
before
and it's shocking it's like
a 911 type shock to the country
but it hit so close to home to those
inside those
chambers that's why you're seeing what
you're
seeing now will it go away quickly i
would imagine it'll stay for a little
while
uh things will have to calm down because
like you said the rhetoric
it's not going to stop now it becomes
what will will it become a payback
scenario for
how the impression is of what was done
to donald trump
so are we now going to try to do that to
joe biden
i think yes we've had i think was
marjorie taylor green
said she's going to file for impeachment
day one day one so so here we go
i mean is is it possible we hit that
ceiling where this is the level of
tension we get
and then we never cross into that
territory of actual disruption of supply
lines and fighting
it's possible but what's going to happen
now groups are going to start to try to
vie for attention so there was uh there
was a
highway that was stopped by a black
lives matter group
which we haven't seen in a little bit
right that seemed to has calmed down but
everybody now is
going to vie for the attention of the
incoming
uh administration and so the
administration comes in with
like a like a debit card of
capital influence and depending on how
it's spent
it either will grow or it will dissipate
and so everybody wants to make sure the
attention's on
them so they can get a piece of all that
and an important aspect to really
remember here a lot of the left has been
incentivized by making a lot of noise
making a lot of trouble creating a lot
of violence and then being heard
so there's also an example of them
literally looting rioting and then
getting their way so
that's another thing to consider moving
forward in this larger kind of political
spectrum getting defended by kamala
harris and joe biden's administration
so you know you know what's interesting
is we didn't get this reaction when we
had black lives matter riots
sweeping across the country i mean did
you you guys didn't activate the ranches
when all those riots were happening no
no but the election you did we did so
the way we cover our members is there's
a anxiety clause so if something happens
locally if we're not completely
activated officially
they can come you know they're a member
they they can come if
something happens locally because
there's no way to predict how these
things are going to go
so so if let's say like so you're west
virginia if somebody lives and say
pennsylvania and there's a major
disaster in their town
yes they can come to the ranch
absolutely because it's about you know
their survival they can't just go
anywhere i'd love somewhere to go right
right on so i guess you know when we're
looking at what's going on in dc and
everything's happened over the past 10
years the escalation i mentioned that
article where they talk about security
experts giving their predictions
do you think that we are on track for
some kind of political
instability i'm not going to say you
know civil war but instability to the
point where you will have your members
coming in for safety and security well
so it depends things are so fresh
things are very raw we so we rate these
things we give out certain
um levels for
when we put out our newsletters to our
members so that they understand what the
different factors are
you know whether it be from uh something
happening with nuclear to
to a war all of the different factors
that you have to worry about
and we have at a five percent right now
as far as
um what is the danger for civil unrest
and five percent in the sense of how it
would affect
uh we're always looking towards the
collapse scenario
yeah however you get there probably
through a few crises right
yeah yeah so you know just like kovid
coveted was a wake-up call because we
were completely unprepared
again that was a 9 11 event something
you don't prepare for you don't see
coming
and boom there it is but you know we've
been talking about it for a while
and the fact is we're
we're talking about 1.8 mobility
that's the nerve agent so then um
what happens if that was five percent
we'd already this would be a completely
different climate and that's not even
talking ab
bio engineered type
of viruses it's doable
we don't believe that that's what
happened with with kovid but it is
doable that technology exists
and that should be enough to scare
anyone you know again we're not doomsday
you know type prepper people we believe
the world's ending tomorrow and
all this type of thing but the fact that
that is out there
and can be released really should be an
eye-opener and i'll just mention too you
mentioned the nerve agent for those that
uh
before the show you mentioned that what
you're you're uh
you're in i think iraq and you got swept
over by sarin
yeah well yeah it was during desert
storm when we finally wound up there
so that i just want to give quick
context i definitely want to get into
that stuff later but
people are probably wondering what you
meant when you pointed your head and
said nerve agent yeah if i
if i get blocked and thought it's it's
just the synapsis
is trying to reconnect up there well
specifically what you were talking about
before was
gain of function studies that have
proven to have no scientific basis at
all but is pretty much when scientists
come together
and they're literally trying to create
the worst destructive disease or virus
possible
and a lot of times this is funded by a
lot of uh taxpayer-funded money
and everyone's scratching their head
like why is this going on dr fauci was a
part of financing this is also in wuhan
and just the fact that they continue
this type of research is something to of
course worry about which is why i think
you're putting it in your
right assessment weaponization yeah i
think i think i think it's simple you
say there's no scientific benefit of
course they they it's the new frontier
of
war right yeah it's horrifying what they
did i mean you look at the i mean
mustard gas you look at sarin gas you
look at what these things do to people
agent orange yeah nightmare nightmarish
horrifying well the next level up is a
self-replicating contagion
imagine if you could make sarin gas but
would replicate itself and spread to
other people
well that's that's part of this research
i can only imagine
that the military's got some crazy stuff
did you prep the story about the
scientists who said he
had well it's from the daily caller the
title is u.s scientist who led charge
against covet lab the
uh leak theory admits he was trying to
protect chinese scientists so this guy
came out and said
it did not leak from the chinese lab and
he now he admits that he was trying to
protect the chinese scientists
so so we we don't have any confirmation
of the lab leak theory but i will say
it's strange the new york i think was
new york magazine it's always
i think you're amazing they uh they
wrote an article
going through the theory that it was
i guess the idea is they were trying to
do research on it either to make a
vaccine
and i'm not saying it's true youtube
calm down this is what was published in
a prominent new york publication where a
guy wrote that there is a very real
theory among scientists that it was an
accidental release
that they were at they were engineering
this for a variety of reasons and made a
mistake yeah
there's also some video footage going
around showing how
one of the scientists at this level
three wuhan lab was actually bitten by a
bat
and had had covid like symptoms all the
way back a few years ago but there's
as you were saying it's almost
impossible to prove
that it did come out of that lab
especially with china
locking out the world health
organization for over a year from even
investigating the origins of the
sickness but but kind of continuing back
on the military aspect since you were in
the military
i really specifically was was dying to
ask you what do you think it does to
morale to be vetted like we're seeing
the vetted going on right now and how is
the political
kind of climate affecting the military
and how do you think it would be
affected from your experience in the
middle
you know it's an interesting question
because certainly during my time and
never experienced anything like that we
never had
such heightened political tension that
it was really a factor when you you sat
around in the barracks or something
it really wasn't you know part of my
experience but i i can tell you
from anybody who is serving who has
served
it's like a slap in the face
it's something you take pride in i mean
i think it's one percent of all of all
of the 330 some odd million people
only one percent serve yeah and i have
to imagine
of these 12 guards that got removed they
probably have a lot of friends
who are still there on the mission and i
can only imagine
they're not happy about being being
removed i'm sure they kind of just say
like yeah you know that's that's the
game
you get orders you follow your orders
well they'll do their duty
right that when it comes down to it
they'll do their duty but
but like you mentioned a slap in the
face i have to imagine their friends
probably feel
you know loyal to their friends you know
someone you serve with someone you know
when you trust and then they say no this
person's not trustworthy get them out of
here
and you're like dude come on like what's
what's the what's the what's the deal
you know well you're deemed as a threat
for liking something online
or retweeting something now we don't
know what would you guess
dude the symbol of the american
revolution a symbol of the american
revolution
is grounds for removing you from your
duty to protect the capital to the nra
people that have so that's yeah part
part of jack pacific's threat is they're
saying that some people who like posted
or associated with the nra
it's all it's insane that's correct i
kind of mixed feelings like
you need to protect your military and if
you have traitors in the military that's
a problem but
assuming that these people are traitors
there's also can be a problem
and that's a that's a dark road that's i
mean that's a big word
traitor the pro the problem is well i
think the the legal definition of trader
is actually providing
aid or resource to an active enemy of
the united states
so i think you know trader gets thrown
around a whole lot the problem is
when it comes to people storming into
the capitol those people thought they
were the patriots
that by going in there they were
restoring the constitution defending it
and that the people in the chamber they
believed were the bad guys it's
everybody's the hero of their own story
yeah
it's not so simple so so the most
powerful thing in this whole situation
is the media narrative
which is why we're now what two uh just
about two weeks out from the storm with
us capital
every day it's been like 50 stories in a
variety of ways
many of which are just ridiculous many
of which just are trying as hard as
possible to make it as crazy as possible
there was one story that came out where
they said it was pre-planned and they
were planning on capturing
taking hostages and assassinating these
people and then like three hours later
that wasn't true we made a mistake so
that's what happens when the media is
driven to pump out the most sensational
insane you know media and i think for a
lot of the people who work for these
news outlets
they're ideologically tribal left
so it fits their narrative and it fits
their bias and they get to write about
this nonstop
and that it's it's everything they
wanted it was it was probably this one
of the stupidest things
anyone could have done is storm into
that capital for a variety of reasons
it's on moral grounds legal grounds
and then in actual reference to the
political landscape gave the left
everything that could have wanted that
there i remember there was i think i'm
not sure if it was newsweek i think it
was newsweek
where they said if trump loses in 20 it
was like in 2016
what happens if trump loses and it's a
picture of a bunch of like middle-aged
white people holding torches and yelling
and screaming
and they're like that's what's gonna
happen if trump loses and then trump won
and it was the left that you know kind
of went nuts and we're screaming and the
democrats went after trump trying to
impeach him
well sure enough trump loses this time
and they got their
their prophecy fulfilled by people
storming that capital and they're not
going to let it go they're going to use
it for all it's worth
yeah there there's a new video going
around today that's called hashtag
trump's new army yeah and uh
it's pretty much calling trump
supporters traitorous terrorists
uh brett weinstein called this out i saw
it from him retweeting it saying this is
essentially trying to get your neighbors
into a civil war
so this is brett weinstein's commentary
on the video that is making its round
around kind of liberal check marks do
you have an opinion about maybe
what happened on the capital or this
kind of political climate that that
seems to be getting
more and more weaponized against each
other
right we we definitely have entered into
a period of lost perspective
no one can understand why the other
person feels that way
and we we need to take a step back as a
country and
look at our you know fellow man
differently because
not everyone's the enemy just because
they voted one way
or the other i i honestly i i don't
quite
understand why the line is
drawn so harshly the way that it's been
drawn but this has been building up for
a while
i mean the signs have all been there but
you know when you actually see it
uh erupt like it has then
you know you really
[Music]
have to understand that we're still the
same people we were four years
ago i mean let's let's all calm down for
a second
i i think there's a the ideology is
drifting too far too fast
and uh i think you know people they'll
call me a bias but i think the left is
drifting very very for it
i shouldn't it's not necessarily to the
left but the tribal division
is coming from those associated with
more of the left faction the android
groups the example i give is you know
the journalist from cnn i should call
the journalist the activist from cnn
who's now calling up cable providers and
telling them to ban
fox news four years ago this guy
interviewed me about defending free
speech
so he's part of this group that has just
drifted further and further into the
extremes i'm sitting in the exact same
place
defending free speech and all that but i
wanna i wanna i wanna pull up this tweet
from brett weinstein and get into this
and we'll talk about this divide
brett weinstein tweeted in response to a
tweet from don winslow
who says new video trump's new army
volume
up on january 20th donald trump will no
longer be the commander-in-chief
he will lose control of the u.s armed
forces and take
control of a new army brett weinstein
says this video is diabolical
painting millions of citizens not only
as dis disloyal to the nation
but as literal terrorists as it attempts
to draft the rest
into fighting their neighbors in a civil
war the filmmakers clearly desire
i stand with all patriots against this
madness
and so we have this uh this is the tweet
from brett and then uh it was a
different tweet so this is the video he
posted
and uh i don't wanna i'm not gonna play
through the whole thing because i think
it's it's disturbing and
it's quite long but it shows regular
people
at a trump rally and says this army it's
just people who showed up
these are people waving american flags
what they don't realize or
what i think they don't care about is
that at the
at dc you had hundreds of thousands of
people cheering for the president as he
gave one of his last big public events
then you had a few thousand march on the
capitol grounds
and a few hundred went inside those
people are all being arrested
it was a stupid thing to do they
shouldn't have done it they're gonna
arrested for it well so be it
but the overwhelming majority hundreds
of thousands of people
didn't do or say anything to anybody
they showed up there was one guy who
lost his uh
record label buddha was his name ariel
pink ariel pink
because he was just there and he said i
went and saw the speech and then went
went back home there's a a an
intelligence a
psychological uh operations officer
being investigated
for simply bringing people to see the
president speak and then going back to
hotel
that's how like insane things are
getting
and so i know they'll say i'm biased
and they like to uh you know assign your
your
whether you're left or right not based
on what you believe but based on who you
defend i guess
but when you have a dude coming out
putting a video up
encouraging civil war and telling people
to fight their neighbors
that's not coming from the right the
right is the
the worst of the worst conspiracies we
get from the right are pointed at global
elites bankers
politicians the left is targeting
working-class people
regular americans walking around on the
ground that's why you know i i talk
about this
we talk about civil war i'm not saying
it's a good thing i think it's a bad
thing
and i'm saying so long as these people
keep advocating for things like this and
putting these videos out
they're not getting banned when they do
this it is people like brett weinstein
who had unity party
trying to bring people together nope
banned it's conservative
banned unity got banned yep how did why
did it get banned no idea no one knows
are you familiar with the unity party so
uh brett weinstein
is a professor he's a smart fellow and
he wanted to get a left uh left-wing
individual and a right-wing individual
and have them run on the same ticket
to unify as much of the left and the
right as possible to stop this divide
and social media nuked his campaign just
outright removed it
yeah we're in a toxic environment and
that's not going away anytime soon you
know i talked about the five percent but
that was of the day
you know as we we daily update so so do
you mean like a five percent chance is
that that means
right that in the sense of even what
what would happen tomorrow
so we're we're not activated right we
don't believe it's going
that's kind of high it is yeah it was 1
in 20.
so you have it's the reasons it's the
cascading effects behind
all this it's never just one thing it's
how this continues to build
and you know i don't know how small or
if there will be a honeymoon period for
the incoming uh administration but
wherever luke and i are taking no no no
i doubt it too because of this toxic
situation and we're going to get so
so many precedences have been stomped
upon
that there's no end in sight let me ask
you the tough question
what if you have members who are
staunchly anti-trump
i mean you don't screen people's
politics when they no no we don't
what happens if you've got people who
are you know come in there saying donald
trump's destroyed this country
the conflict is all his fault and then
they show up one day and there's another
guy who says
biden destroyed this country it's all
the democrats fault and they walk up to
each other guys got a gadsden flag in
america and the other guy's wearing
biden or whatever
well if we have to come together those
things don't matter anymore
yeah because things fell apart and then
people will get
perspective i think that's actually the
you know one thing we mentioned before
we
talked about before we started the show
you mentioned these silos where
millionaires will get bunkers and stuff
i think actually one thing that makes
what you guys do
what makes it work more than anything
else is you have leadership
you have people like you who are running
it who will be the ones to intervene and
say
shut your mouth if you want to survive
stop fighting over this stuff absolutely
and and see that's that's really the
only way it will work
because you know people try to do this
either on their own or they try to do it
in smaller groups
but it generally ends in confrontation
either financially
or over how all this is going to work
and then they'll reach out and contact
us and say do you want to purchase this
land and stuff because
we you know we no longer can do this we
get that all the time
because without structure it's not going
to work
you're talking about people coming under
an extremely stressful situation
and if if there isn't something already
in place
it'll be chaos now um before you made a
very good point
you're saying that people just need to
take a step back i mean that's something
me and you have been talking about for
years like calm down relax
take a step back stop escalating these
things stop the cycle of hate
uh that that's been perpetrated by the
mainstream media but it looks like we're
definitely full steam ahead on the
divide and conquer train
and there's no stopping it how bad if it
would get really bad
do you see it getting because as you
said it's a slippery slope we've been
seeing it for a while
but the snowball that started it's
already getting pretty big
what would be the worst possible
scenario that you would see unfolding
from here
well i we're i think again in order to
get attention for an incoming
administration
we're going to see an uptick in some
kind of unrest those looking to
get the attention on to them so that
then they can promote
whatever it is they're looking to
promote so then that
is going to upset those who are against
whatever they are promoting
and so we're not going to see a low
we'll see
a consistent rebutting of heads
and then it really depends on what the
local governments do so much of this
depends on what the politicians do
in order to make this go away to a
certain degree and calm it down or not
so you had the the chop chad's thing
which you guys i'm sure
talked about oh you know yeah so many
times but
so when that leader comes out and says
the summer of love
and she probably believed it i mean
i i have no idea right that was her
perspective at the time or was just
something to be said politically
but then it it completely collapses and
it it shows you
what's going on now i know that's been
tried you know in a couple of different
places in some
other ways but law enforcement already
cut that off they've seen it so
um so we won't necessarily see the same
things
it's the one you don't see coming and
that's what we're going
to you know you you gotta they'll have
to be on guard for
but there'll be things that will take us
by surprise these people
uh these people who are advocating for
conflict i don't care which faction
what your ideology is left right
whatever many of them actually now
i think it's fair to say more so on the
left than the right they have no idea
what they're asking for
i think with with conservatives you're
more likely to find people who
live in rural areas who have fired guns
and who understand
conflict and and these threats not
completely but
definitely more so than the left uh so i
i guess
i don't wanna you know um maybe make an
issue of it for you guys but if you can
answer
do you tend to see more conservatives
than liberals
i would i mean i say it would be fair
from what you know
those who i know and when groups have
come out i would say definitely
you you can say that it leans that way
but
it's not a big part of even their
mentality when they come out
they're trying to get away from that you
understand that that's
uh they want to escape all of
this butting of heads and all the
rhetoric and
and all the you know insidious talk you
know
towards one you know partisan political
politics is insane but it's but it's
tribal now it's beyond parties
like when you have two parties you're
like your party is wrong now it's tribe
it's like you are the enemy
and what scares me is i got out of egypt
just before they started just gunning
down the muslim brotherhood
so you had uh you know this is 2013
you had the second revolution in a year
and the problem was the muslim muslim
brotherhood was the largest voting bloc
so they kept they were going to win the
election but it was creating instability
because most of the country
was to a certain degree secular and
didn't want to vote for this one faction
so a minority faction winning elections
was creating this instability so the
military said here's the answer
kill him and that's what happened so if
we're really entering this period and
this freaks me out because other people
have brought up stuff like this and
i hate to even you know kind of talk
about this stuff but if we're at the
point
where you have different sides vying for
the attention going out there protesting
escalating
street battles already over the past
several years between the warring tribes
not the most
like you know insane in terms of the
things i've seen and would have happened
in other countries but yes still death
still some pretty shocking and extreme
scenarios trump supporter getting shot
in the chest walking down the street
twice by this dude and the
law enforcement goes and kills this guy
we're getting to that point
my fear is if this instability doesn't
stop
do we come to a point where those in
power just say
gun those people down get rid of those
people that's the wrong tribe whoever's
in power takes it
no you can never stop the instability
and the only way that you could is if
they became a totalitarian dictatorship
that shoved us inside and said that's no
more instability but that's why i'm
saying they'll always be instantly well
but
they'll go for the guns before they
start shooting themselves
yeah that's the only course that makes
sense it's really interesting to hear
from
uh one of the common talking points from
the left on guns is
that you can't go up against the us
military they have nukes
and cruise missiles and fighter jets
it's amazing because they've never heard
of vietnam or afghanistan
so the government really does have to go
after guns before they can do anything
to lock down the people or be
totalitarian and you can 3d print guns
now so
yeah it's kind of like if you have a
like a like a cnc machine or
you know don't they have metal 3d
printers even definitely
you can you can be manufacturing all the
stuff very easily and cheaply now a lot
of people can
not only that but there's the the what's
what's the gun that can shoot one time
before it breaks
the ghost gun there's there's a plastic
gun that can take one round and then it
goes
fires and then breaks interesting
because if it breaks but a lot of them
do break easily yeah
3d printing is not as advanced as people
think it is a lot of liberals think
that you could just click print and get
a fully automatic machine gun that's
not how it works they thought glocks
would not be able to be detected by
metal detectors
because they don't understand what gun
parts are exactly so they really there's
some guns that are made with you know
plastic but again they don't last that
long they are very difficult to make you
can make certain components for it but
making a full firing firearm is very
very difficult with 3d printing to be
completely honest with you
uh but i i we're kind of jumbled a
little bit but i wanted to get your
perspective do you think that's a fair
kind of
analysis of of the vietnam reference
when it comes to the united states
especially in our current kind of
political crisis do you think there
could be a similar kind of
um conflict
it's possible you wouldn't have said
that again you know
four years ago that that would have you
know i think back it was october
of 2019 when the washington post came
out
and uh did an interview viewed
the the ranch um
[Music]
you know the very things that we talked
about i don't mean that like i told you
so in
any scenario like that because this is
just what we do this is what we pay
attention
but civil unrest we talked about
epidemics we
we talked about all these things that
are going on
uh in when the article comes out you
know the
the hatred underneath all the remarks
and things people just had
could not believe that that could
possibly happen even then
and now we're two steps past that
now we're going to have a financial
reckoning yeah that's what i was going
to bring up because i was going to say
we were just talking about politically
and there's a big chance that something
like a new kind of popular occupy wall
street could happen
there's a chance of that but the more
likelihood kind of scenario is economic
that a lot of people aren't really
looking at that i think is the huge kind
of tsunami
that we're still not seeing the
ramifications it's the cascading effect
so we
to us to reach that point it's going to
it's going to be continued
lockdowns and or different variants will
come out of covet as we're already
starting to see in the news
which continues this it's this long
process that wears people out
and then the you know the straw the
bricks the camel's back will be
coming for people's guns it's a perfect
time for me to bring up i pulled up the
washington post article
and there's a perfect quote for what you
just said from uh this is from drew
miller
quote you know people use the term civil
war and that seems hard to imagine
but what started world war one some guy
assassinated a minor archduke
stuff escalates unpredictably yep that's
it the straw that breaks the camel back
you don't know what it's going to be or
when or how
i think it's oh sorry no no no no it's
the liberator was that gun you were
thinking of it's a one-shot 3d
printable pistol and a ghost gun is a
gun oh it's full plastic though
yeah the firing pin is a firing pin
plastic too i think the entire thing was
i don't know to be honest um
they printed it it was like one of the
first guns they ever 3d printed in 2013
and it shoots once and then it breaks a
ghost gun breaks but i think
uh it's it it doesn't have that many
rounds that you could shoot with it yeah
yeah this
calls it a one-shot pistol yeah you have
to reload that thing you put one in and
it fires
and they did break a lot in the early
days it was like you had to pull the
trigger with the like a
with a string from far away because it
could explode in your hand
not reliable and a ghost gun is a gun
that's printed without a serial number
yeah right there's probably is that is
that legal no i don't think no you're
supposed to no
yeah you can't do that yeah but was the
american revolution legal
well no that dude um what was that guy's
name in
in in was it tacoma or olympia or
whatever who showed up at the ice
facility
yeah he had a ghost gun yeah he he made
a weapon and he showed up and was
firebombing
and and it's it's all been this
cycle of gradual escalation that i think
a lot of it
comes from the media a lot of the
tensions the the people being inflamed
crazy it's it's not just the mainstream
media though it's social media
like look at this this clip from uh from
uh you know this guy drew what's his
name let me pull that brett weinstein
thing back up
um don winslow this this this
what is this let me see what he's got 22
000
retweets 3.8 million views 3.8 million
views
these people are being radicalized by
some random dude well is he random let's
see how many followers he got a verified
account he's got 636
000 followers these people are psychotic
i'm sorry man
i i i repeatedly on all of my segments
say you don't want this
tone it down stop doing this stop saying
these things
and what do they do they make more
videos they ramp it up they go crazy
like i said man if you follow all these
q anon people and these conspiracy
things i think it's nuts
but what are they complaining about
global elites the one percent the
bankers the the politicians
there's some issues with that for sure
you know some people get their lives
threatened and that's not a good thing
and there have been politicians people
tried to kill it's terrible
but these people are making videos
targeting regular americans
just because they're wearing a red hat
or waving a gadsden flag that kind of
amping up is coming mostly from the left
and it's going to result in more
extremism in the and the targeting of
regular people and i've seen it
i remember in i think it was 2015 i
watched an elderly couple
get shoved to the ground their hats
ripped off and set on fire i've seen
regular people just walking on the
street get punched because they thought
the person was a trump supporter all
this has been piling up
and that's why i've been saying for some
time that i think we're headed towards
whatever you want to call it i don't
know civil war would you like to say
that
maybe maybe drew is more correct when he
said
things escalate unpredictably we don't
know what when or how
you know we'll be that main catalyst
that shot heard around the world
no idea hopefully uh
it doesn't go that far no and you know
circling back to what we were talking
about even about that five percent you
know
chance that something you know can
escalate
and and that could actually happen the
idea is that's not happening tomorrow
there's things that are going to have to
take place you know when i say right
you know calm down folks it's not going
to happen tomorrow
but it could happen tomorrow well we'll
be struck by a meteor tomorrow
no we've got 25 000 national guard in dc
right now worried because of a threat of
armed militia groups
occupying the capital there have been
literal statements
from individuals not prominent
individuals there was one guy got
arrested for leaving a voicemail saying
he he's not i don't want to repeat what
he said but he threatened
to go down and and do some crazy stuff
with people
and and they arrested the guy right but
so in order for what we're talking about
to happen
something has to be organized this again
there still has to be
there are things that need to take place
i truly believe we're heading down that
path
and depending on what our politicians do
it will direct that path one way or
another
but then you throw in the media
jumping all over it it doesn't even have
to be just for political reasons
it's sometimes it's just about money and
it's just about the influence and the
power that's gained over that
uh you know there's there's so many
factors
but it's definitely building for sure
well you when you have
democrats look you had ted cruz and a
variety of
some other individuals calling for unity
and the response from
ocasio-cortez was no resign now or be
expelled
so if if the established republicans are
like chill
we'll we'll unify and the democrats say
no
and don't get me wrong you had democrats
after the election saying republicans
let's unify republicans said no
so it's really just like incongruity
neither side is willing to back down
and now the media has been shoving this
capital right in everyone's faces
it's crazy there's a video of a guy in a
maga hat walking up to cops
and saying why aren't you doing anything
call for backup this is the capital
call for backup trying to stop what was
going on
i saw this on reddit and the comments
were whoa a sane trump supporter that's
crazy
when you see comments like that that
this idea that
every single trump supporter is is a
[ __ ] or psychotic or a cue conspiracy
theorist
that's leading to this conflict it means
that you're reading too much reddit
no it means that you've got genk yuger
of the young turks doing
an op-ed for the hill where he said you
have three factions
the leftists the the establishment and
the right-wing conspiracy nut jobs who
are all stupid believe fake news
and i'm like i wouldn't even say that
about the left i'll say there are
prominent figures that are driving this
that are escalating it
but i i try to separate the
establishment from leftists because
there are leftists
who i think are good people and i think
you know i disagree with or have bad
ideas that's about it
and that's that's like the old saying
you know conservatives think that
liberals are misguided liberals think
conservatives are evil
when you have videos like this saying
they're all evil it's just gonna
it's gonna get crazy but i i don't know
man you know
a lot of people like to say that it's
it's something the left has no idea what
they're getting themselves into because
conservatives are more likely to be
armed and prepared and know what's going
on
but i'm not entirely convinced it would
be so one-sided
i think if there really was some kind of
conflict it's probably going to be urban
versus rural
that's like a big driving factor for
whatever reason different cultures
and there's going to be things that
people on one side or this side don't
control or don't have and it'll make
things very difficult for everybody
which is why
anybody who talks big on this stuff and
wants it to happen has has
i think there's no idea what they're
talking about yeah they're clueless
there are some people who have emailed
me saying
you know because i've said this over and
over again you know people who really
want this have no idea what combat and
conflict is really like
and i've gotten emails from people
saying that they served in the army or
the marines
or you know they've been overseas in
conflict and know exactly what they're
talking about
there are people who are staunch you
know believers in traditional america
and and the constitution and all of this
stuff
and they're ready and willing and angry
and they and there are some people who
who know exactly what it means
and that's freaky i think the problem is
then you're the left which is the
opposite factor
and they're just angry and they don't
know what they're asking for so the
ignorance is driving them
yeah you have a you you definitely have
a a combination
um that is going to
again i always go back to what what the
politicians
do with this right it's not like they're
unaware
and so what what happens
to either fuel we know what the media is
going to do they're just going to fuel
it that's
they're in the business to do that
whatever side you're on
that's how you make money but look at
look at someone like ocasio-cortez
in order to make money for in donations
she does the exact same thing
she ramps up the escalation the tensions
she snap back clap
clap backs at the republicans always the
republicans of the worst they're always
bad
right because she well she's vying to
get power right she's
she has not been in there that long and
so it's also a power play on her side
to again you know politics is all about
that influence
in in gaining all that backing in order
to do what you think
is right to do whatever that may be and
you know she's not there yet so that's
part of how she's playing it
well let's jump to uh this this next
story which kind of feeds into this we
have this from the hill
hillary clinton said i would love to see
if trump quote
was talking to putin the day the
insurgents
invaded our capital what it's just
ridiculous
but it's all about playing to the tribal
politics
and finding the boogeyman to rally their
base and go after the other side
and the next story part of the same
story is that
clinton pelosi call for 9 11 style
commission
into the capital riot and putin's role
so there's no sign of de-escalation i
mean
let me read a little bit so we get some
context here they say there is strong
support in the congress for establishing
a 911 style commission to investigate
trump's ties to vladimir putin
and russian involvement in the capital
riot in an interview on clinton's
podcast you and me both released monday
pelosi made the revelation after the
2016 democratic presidential candidate
discussed her concerns
that the outgoing commander-in-chief was
compromised by the kremlin
we learned a lot about our system of
government over the last four years
with a president who disdains democracy
and as
as you have said numerous times has
other agendas what they all are i don't
think we yet know
i hope historically we will find out who
he's beholden to who pulls his strings
the former secretary of state got
specific questioning whether he spoke to
putin
i would love to see if his phone records
i would love to see his phone records to
see whether he was talking to putin the
day
the insurgents invaded our capital we
now know that not just him but his
enablers
his accomplices his cult members have
the same disregard for democracy
asked by clinton whether the nation
needs a 911
911 type commission to investigate and
report everything they can pull together
pelosi said i do
as i said to him in the picture with my
blue suit as i was leaving
what i was saying to him as i was
pointing rudely at him with you mr
president all roads lead to putin
the top house democrat said at the
outset of a reply
going on to say she does not know what
putin has on him politically
financially or personally but what
happened last week was a gift to putin
because putin wants to undermine
democracy in our country
and throughout the world we had we had
the whole
mueller probe it was a 30 plus million
dollars spent
coming up with nothing and now here we
go again mueller probe 2.0 i mean
this is just like q anon paranoia level
stuff conspiracy theories made up
pretty much suggesting that that putin
was ordering donald trump during the
capital siege how
naive how insane how of how much of a
crazy person do you have to be to go
there based off absolutely no evidence
at all hyperbolic theorization
of the worst possible scenario that you
could imagine but yet again
pushing a very russian phobic uh kind of
narrative
russian phobic uh kind of policy that
we've seen
from from the previous administrations
we also have seen mitt romney call for
more russian sanctions today
so we're going to see another big pivot
towards a very aggressive foreign policy
against russia
against of course its major allies
within the entire world
and and why isn't this stuff banned you
know you know who doesn't like russia
succeeding
china oh yeah that's right well yeah
well they're
like they're they're like in a quasi
kind of alliance but they're also at
odds in certain aspects
historically as well but why isn't this
paranoia why isn't this fake news why
isn't this conspiracy theory
banned on twitter on facebook on youtube
hillary clinton should have her podcast
taken down immediately
for violations of terms and services and
spreading well bad information that
doesn't help anyone
and is based off no truth at all with no
evidence we're not at that point where
they're banning podcasts yet but they're
trying
so there's been a series of of articles
where they're like podcasts are where
the real radicalization happens
and they point out that a bunch of
podcasters had their youtube channels
banned or twitter banned but they're
still
on itunes and spotify so it's coming but
the bigger question is
you know twitter banned 70 000 people
for be for posting
cue related content not not even
outright conspiracy stuff it was people
i believe for the most part in this
leaked video guy from project veritas
they were mostly talking about
the election you know voter fraud and
things like that
so twitter bans them but what about the
people who said the exact same thing
four years ago and are saying the exact
same thing now
the fact that we have someone like jack
dorsey and vijaya gaday
saying we accept this tribe's unhinged
conspiracy but not this one
to me it's like jack dorsey wants
people to kill each other and the reason
i say this and and the reason why i've
been very harsh on the man
is because i sat in front of him and
said if you keep doing what you are
doing
you will create civil unrest and
potentially some kind of civil war
and then i was like i'm building a van
get ready to bug out because of what's
happening in this country
and they laughed and said it was silly
and so dumb and i got emails from people
saying you're so silly you're so crazy
and then i got emails from people a year
ago saying man you were right
and i got emails from people different
people in the past couple of weeks being
like dude
i've got people tweeting at me now like
wow maybe tim was right about all this
yeah when you have billionaires in
silicon valley
telling american citizens you are not
allowed to participate
in this conversation but the ayatollah
can chinese ambassadors can lie and
smear
our soldiers and they can post pictures
of australian soldiers
slitting the throat of children they can
post that great it was an artistic
render a render of it
that's allowed twitter allows this and
only after massive outcry to do anything
about it
but they will proactively purge people
on the right
recently there was a post from china
about why it was good
they're operating concentration camps
and they left it
and they told these journalists it does
not violate our rules and it was only
after basically everybody said dude
allowing china to post in favor of
concentration camps kind of messed up
they finally took it down they
proactively go after conservatives
think about how how dangerous this is
when you have an american citizen who is
expressing their opinion on their
political preference
you ban them for that preference then
you have an australian citizen go on
twitter
and say anything he wants and it
influences our elections
and they allow it eventually you're
going to get a bunch of angry americans
watching european australian or canadian
policies be running amok
on in our political discourse in our
news and they're cut out
they're going to lose it they already
nuked parlor
right and that's that's one of the
cascading effects is definitely going to
be the assault on free speech
and that is going to be one of those key
elements
that will bring about individual events
that then build again to that point
where we're really going to see a
problem but
it's interesting so a point of
perspective having been
you know spending 12 years in the
country of belarus which is just outside
of russia proper
um and basically you know it's like the
the they have a very awkward uh
relationship trying to be a small
independent nation but
so much of the russian news is so
anti-american you wouldn't believe it
it's
everybody does need the boogeyman and
you know we are theirs and it's sort of
this frenemy situation
uh but it'd be interesting to see how
the
the incoming administration what kind of
relationship they're going to try to
have oh it's completely
it's clearly antagonistic to russia at
least it's favorable to china
you know in that regard try and prevent
war in the in the pacific
but that's not good either what china is
doing with the uyghur camps
what they're doing with hong kong it is
it is what nightmares are made of well
it was also officially declared today
this is also news that happened
that china was declared to be committing
genocide by the united states especially
when it comes to
the uyghur muslim population so that
news also just happened today by the way
so we have the story here from cnn u.s
accuses china of genocide of uyghurs
and minority groups in xinjiang which
i'm pronouncing wrong
they say quote the genocide is ongoing
and we are witnessing the systematic
attempt to destroy uyghurs by the
chinese party state
u.s secretary of state mike pompeo said
in a statement on tuesday
the last full day of the trump
administration since at least march of
2017 local authorities dramatically
escalated their decades-long campaign
of repression against uyghur muslims and
members of other ethnic and religious
minority groups including ethnic kha'zix
and ethnic kirk kurgs kyrgyz i'm sorry i
can't pronounce it properly
yeah kirkus the u.s state department has
previously estimated that the two
million uyghurs as well as
uh as well as well as members of other
muslim minority groups
have been detained in a sprawling
network of internment camps in the
region
former re-education camp detainees have
told cnn they experienced political
indoctrination
and abuse inside the camps such as food
and sleep deprivation and forced
injections cnn reporting has also found
that some uyghur women were
forced to use birth control and undergo
sterilization as part of a deliberate
attempt to push down birth rates
among minorities in xinjiang that's the
level of depravity going on in china
so it is kind of worrying that you know
you you have the binding transition team
which includes people who have been
favorable and defensive of china and now
they're trying to shift all the focus
onto russia
i i get it russia's you know we're
adversaries in
a manner of speaking but they're nowhere
near as as big a threat as say china is
that's kind of being ignored yeah it's a
it'll be interesting because the real
threat comes when
china and russia decide
that they're going to unite and then
then you have a real problem
i mean we have the safety of having
borders that know there's no large army
that can come across
but well those canadians man you got to
watch out
well they started working with the
chinese military and doing drills
very near the u.s border but china and
russia have already joined in quasi
partnerships economically
also financially with trade and also
militarily by doing many military
exercises together
geopolitically they're usually on the
same side when it comes to iran
syria and they kind of have a weird
relationship where historically they
were at odds with each other and
it's still kind of tense but they do
have a mutual common enemy and that of
course is the united states so if there
would be a conflict with one there would
be a conflict most likely with another
in one way or another with either
support
or actual even bigger presence of a
bigger alliance together yeah absolutely
we you know we're powerful enough that
we can defend ourselves right
say today right now but all these
internal struggles is what's going to
bring others
and we get to that point of you know
unrest or to the point of civil war well
then you can
expect our borders to look i see foreign
troops i was bullish
three years ago i'm bullish now you know
it was it was years ago i was watching
the political tensions escalate between
antifa
and and groups like the proud boys and i
was talking about my fear
of a coming civil war and i guess what a
lot of people didn't realize is that my
experience was coming from occupy wall
street
i watched hundreds of thousands of
people i i traveled all over the country
during occupy
and i saw the anger people had and it
wasn't going away it was escalating
the protest died down a little bit but i
could go around anywhere talk to
somebody and they tell me the exact same
things they were mad about
i watched the tactics of these black
block far leftist type smashing windows
and getting crazier and more destructive
as time went on
and eventually got to the point where
you know they were in larger and larger
groups
it became they got they they got a new
colloquial term antifa they didn't have
that back during occupy watcher we just
called it the black bloc
you know left or anarchists because
there was no discernible group
now they fly a flag now they they shared
similar ideologies
then they started going up to trump's
trump rallies and i saw what was going
on with trump
trump supporters were fed up they were
angry the divide was getting crazier
and years ago i said that you know look
i'm reading these stories that are
predicting this stuff
based on what i've seen on the ground
over the past decade it feels like it's
happening
then we get to the point where you know
you have charlottesville
and i'm like dude i'm telling you man
this stuff's getting crazy i feel like
this
you're gonna get a tit for ted after
that then the media lies about what
trump said following the charlottesville
you know the very fine people hoax that
he didn't condemn them he did
and that you should look it up you
should read what you actually said watch
the video you'll be surprised if you
didn't know that already
but then you end up with years of this
of
right-wing groups left-wing groups
fighting and it culminates in a series
of
you know major shootings deaths
we get um aaron danielson was his name
in portland
he's walking down the street some guy
yells puts two bolts in his chest
this guy is then he flees the scene the
feds find him they kill him
we're at the point where a random
shooting occurs where
a guy is killed for being a trumpet we
got one right here
here yeah shoot him boom dead and i was
saying
you see what's going on a year of riots
buildings being smashed
we had in oregon the attorney i believe
was the attorney general
of uh of oregon the ag suing the federal
government
challenging their authority to defend
their own jurisdiction
it was the craziest thing to me to see
oregon's politicians telling the federal
government they had no authority
to stop people from firebombing their
building and i said at that point i was
like is this where we start seeing the
states
challenge federal authority then we
heard from the boston globe
that never trump or republicans and
democrats staged a war game where
john podesta top democrat hillary
clinton type guy
you know in her circle actually said it
would be better for the west coast to
secede from the union than allow trump
to win
and then trump didn't win and what do we
get
the capital gets stormed by trump
supporters i'm not gonna pretend like
it's the
most egregious you know like armed
groups we're like marching on dc
they're trying to compare to the war of
1812 like the british soldiers storming
in come on calm down
but it still is one of the most dramatic
escalations we've seen in this
and if i was reading this stuff years
ago thinking this was going to happen
and we're here now i'm surprised there
are still people who think
nothing is going to happen from this the
media is going nuts
smearing trump supporters they're not
going to just sit back and say okay i
guess we're evil
well so the question now comes to
[Music]
will there be someone
to fill that void
because i think part of the problem was
i mean there did tend to see be a
certain uh
looking to the person more than to the
ideal that you stand for
and uh i mean it's understandable if
that's the only person you feel
is speaking for you so now where where
does
it pivot um you know as we're looking at
the second impeachment which probably
the goal is so that he can't
run again right so you squash that and
then
um you know all the talk that you've
we've been
reading about uh reprogramming and
you know the truth and reconciliation
commissions right so
you you see that
there's trying to be a breakup right of
what is most feared from their angle
and that'll be interesting to see where
that void is
filled and who that person is or that
group
is before anything can really
again get get that traction to do
something
that is uh going to take this
past a tipping point they're they're
pushing more censorship
you know we've had uh i think it was
msnbc host saying people should be
i don't know if it was msnbc i think it
was uh cnn what they were saying banned
facebook outright
it was msnbc they were like i think it
was scarborough saying you provide
nothing i could be getting wrong so
forgive me if i'm picking the wrong
person they might as well create a bill
saying that the internet is only for the
establishment left and that's it no one
else could talk no one else could say
anything
only you if you have the special
regurgitation powers of the
establishment
you get special privileges just like in
china you have a social credit score you
could access certain
things in society if you're a good
little establishment
slave i was going to use a naughty word
there i can't but i'm controlling myself
now
i'm on twitter right now i'm retweeting
a whole bunch of crazy stuff on luke we
are change about the insidious
love of power happening right now with
the establishment growling all over
joe biden we have cnn literally just
moments ago saying that
the sidelights on the national mall's
reflecting pool
are like the extension of joe biden's
arms embracing america
cnn news right now now
saying that specifically david callan of
cnn and then of course
we have lauren wolfie who's at the new
york times the new york times made a
statement saying that they're going to
be critiquing this presidency just like
they did the other one that's their
public kind of word
and and then lauren wolfie says biden
landing at joint base andrew now
i have chills with a photo of of of
course the airplane coming in this is
just a creepy level
yeah this is so here's what people need
to understand the government is
power it's all confidence if if you have
half the country not believing
in the power or the legitimacy of of the
government then they won't have that
power to exert
and that's probably why they're doing
the screenings on these soldiers because
these soldiers are
look we heard from the oath keepers from
stewart rhodes he said that half the
country
will not view anything out of biden's
mouth as legitimate what happens when
soldiers are feeling that way well this
is why they're flexing this is why i
think they have
over 25 000 national guardsmen
showing them look at us we're the
authority we are strong
we are powerful i think this is why the
mainstream media is in overdrive
right now 24 7 non-stop saying biden's
the best he's beautiful he's glorious
he's going to save us
he's going to do everything for us as of
course we all know he's barely there he
represents the special interest
lobbyist more than even barack obama
wanted to be represented
in the u.s government this is going to
be not just about
a new nor back to the new normal this is
a back towards pushing towards a
state that is truly uh at a very
dangerous point
moving forward from here what's what's
the what's the old stereotype of the of
the bar
fight you got some loud boisterous
arrogant dude pushing people around
saying yeah i can do whatever i want
and there's some quiet guy minding his
own business just sipping his drink
and then the guy comes up who's like
come on buddy what are you looking at
and he's like dude just leave me alone i
don't want to get into it
and it's a stereotype of the quiet guy
being the actual tough guy
he doesn't want to fight he wants to be
left alone let me have my drink you do
not want to fight you will regret it
and the guy talking all the smack is the
one who gets smacked down so if they're
coming out
flexing as hard as possible it seems
like a facade yep
like there's they're actually the
actions they're taking scare me
because they have no confidence the fact
that they would vet
our soldiers the fact that chris cuomo
and cnn would say we can't trust our
military i'm like jeez dude they're
scared
issuing that letter you see that letter
that got released
it was a um who was joint chiefs issued
a letter saying
biden one trump is not the president do
not support him or else
then we got all of the the living former
secretaries of defense
published an op-ed in the washington
post saying anyone who supports trump
to to keep him in the presidency will be
prosecuted
the fact they have to put out these
messages send out 25 000 troops vet them
they are terrified that they have lost
control and they have lost confidence
of enough of this country that it's
going to create real instability and
they don't have the power anymore yep
they have everything to prove and
nothing backing it and this is why it's
it's such a scary time because they
could be going for broke
and doing unspeakable things and just
like we mentioned uh before starting the
show
and this is kind of the theme that we've
been talking about in general
uh usually the people who call for
combat violence are usually the ones who
have never experienced it
you experienced it you know what it's
like uh
is there anything you want to say to
some of these kind of radicalized voices
about
you know what you see in a war zone and
the bigger kind of potential dangers
here
yeah well so you have the right the xbox
um player who
gets this false sense of reality like
they understand
combat and they understand tactics and
and they know all that with with with a
controller and
i think it gives sort of this uh false
bravado and maybe a
false sense of they actually think they
know what they're doing
but i mean i i doubt they've seen
charred bodies and people
blown in half from an rpg and someone
they know with a bullet in their head
those things change you those things
never leave you and
while in a war situation it's something
you have to do
it should not be anything you're looking
to do
because you have no idea you can put you
can turn that television off and
you can put that xbox controller down
uh but you witness and or take part in
that violence
you won't sleep right movies online
videos
they do not convey the true experience
of seeing
mangled bodies and one of the most
you you i think a lot of people will not
understand it unless they ever
experience it they think they might
they think they oh i've seen videos
online i've seen nah man i've seen
videos online
and i've also seen people a guy laying
on the ground
with his lower lower legs were roast
beef as he was looking at his
mangled meat and his hands were just not
functioning
and he's trying to move it the feeling
you get when you see that level of
destruction of a human body is something
you will not experience in a movie in a
video game
well it is now clinically proven that
someone with ptsd
that your brain is actually rewired yeah
it happened it physically happens to
your brain
i can't i can't even uh there's it's
crazy i want
desperately to convey the emotion i felt
when i saw a dude whose legs were gone
and he was looking at them
trying to get up and i'm like dude you
can't you can't get up
yeah but people who who like these these
lefties who go and play larp
and they these antifa people throwing
fireworks and stuff
man they they they don't get it there
was a video out of portland and it
and it it was funny and it was sad but
it also made me angry
where a dude got an abrasion from like a
from a
you know one of those phone expanding
foam rounds and so they put a tourniquet
on his leg
i remember they put a tourniquet on his
leg because he had he had an abrasion
with some it was some bleeding and there
he was like don't i don't want to lose
my leg and they're like we got to stop
the bleeding man i'm like
these people if it ever truly came to
the conflict they've been calling for
will cry so hard begging for their xbox
days back
just to go back and have that that papa
john's stuffed crust with the garlic
dipping sauce just one more time
they also don't understand what it's
like to not have resources and to eat
garbage and just man they've not they've
not seen real struggle
they've not left this country many of
them no that's that's a
again i i always go back to that that
perspective you know that pinpointed
perspective when you have nothing else
to rely on
outside of what you've seen in a movie
on television or
you underst i mean you can understand to
a point i mean i
i i oddly enough feel some empathy
just because i understand the
cluelessness
the cluelessness that comes from a lack
of perspective
and we also forget how privileged we are
how amazingly lucky we are
to live in a western world to have the
internet to have everything at our
fingertips
even though we're going through a very
tough economic turmoil
we still have it way better than the
majority of the world and and traveling
the world
and covering some conflict there was
there were some events and things that
i've personally seen in my life that i
just blacked out
i i know i've been there but i i don't
even want to go there i don't even want
to think about it
and this is why i've been always pushing
hey let's try to resolve this
calm down take a step back and and it
and it's very funny because you know
the voices your voice my voice a lot of
other independent media voices that are
trying to
bring reason to this insanity that are
trying to calm things down
those are usually the first ones that
get the nail they get the hammer
hit on them directly by big tech
censorship that is trying to silence
individuals from even
expressing these resolution voices you
know why
well the people who are who are invested
in the conflict
can't have people begging you know
everyone to stop fighting i don't agree
with that
i think the people calming them down are
fine no no what i'm saying is there are
people on the left who want
to fight and in order to justify their
fight they need the people to fight them
so if we come out and we say stop stop
doing this like brett weinstein's unity
party
they nuke it right if you challenge them
and tell them to stop they're going to
come after you but if you're
truly trying to calm people down you're
not telling anyone to stop you're
creating something new
what do you mean you're making a better
place for everyone to go
telling people to stop focusing on the
conflict and the chaos
is different than telling them to start
focusing on growth
and that's what we do well telling
someone to stop is different than
telling someone to do
so einstein didn't tell people to stop
he said let's
bring people together and find where we
agree and do good things
i don't know i didn't i can't speak for
they banned they banned him they banned
him
when you look there's a tactic among
left-wing activists and
and i'm not saying this because i'm
trying to drag the left again it's
because the right is not organized in
this capacity when it comes to protests
they're not organized
that's why all these people from the
capital weren't wearing masks because
they had no idea what they were doing
and that's why they're going to go to
prison it's why when the proud boys got
into a fight with antifa in new york
city
antifa told the cops fu and ran away
even though they were supposedly the
victims
and the proud boys said we'll tell you
everything officer and guess who went to
prison the proud boys
the cops said we would have arrested
antifa we don't know who they are where
they went
because they have strategy they have
organization and they and they know
these tactics work
one of their tactics is to purposefully
get someone falsely arrested they want
a regular person walking down the street
to be thrown to the ground and beaten by
a cop
so what they'll do is they go to
protests of normie you know college
student kids
they go they'll crouch down and they'll
chuck a rock at a cop then the cop will
grab some 22 year old woman
throw her to the ground and she'll be
freaking out why is this happening i
didn't do anything wrong
then once she gets out because they bail
her out they supported her they'll say
don't you see how evil these cops are
you should join our group
shave the side of your head put on this
black hoodie we're the ones who saved
you
it is a common tactic they use get
people to be the victims
they want right-wing individuals at the
proud boys to show up and fight them
that's why i say it's a stupid thing to
do and they shouldn't do it they want it
so they can film it take it out of
context and then show regular people see
they're the bad guys join us
we'll keep you safe when the proud boys
announce they're gonna go march around
with their with their american flags and
their gads and flags what do we hear
from the left
white supremacists are coming to target
minorities and racist attacks
an extreme version of
has not have nothing to do with reality
that's the propaganda technique
so they need the conflict so if we're
going to come out and say y'all you
don't want to fight it's bad
you don't understand how bad it's going
to get they're like no no stop them stop
them
they're actually trying to get people to
calm down that's bad for us well it's
how
listen to my point telling someone to
stop fighting is different than
doing something different that they can
focus on instead of fighting
and if you're telling them to stop you
will draw the aggro of the elite
of the people with money they don't want
to hear you telling people to stop
they want to see you do something new
like write a song or
build a new technology that people can
use i think
ultimately anything that threatens their
you know their the radicalization engine
or their tribe
or their their moral authority and
justification anything that threatens
the flow
at risk the agenda of the narrative
they'll find a way to hit it i mean if
you look at
the youtube purge a lot of it first was
independent media
independent media was screaming about
child abusers radical islamists other
kind of crazy
people and individuals exploiting
whether it was puppies or little
children on the platform they were still
allowed to have a voice the first
crackdown
the first crackdown came on independent
media came on regular mom and pop
small shops of individuals saying i want
to be a youtuber i want to share the
news from a perspective
that's not from a corporate special
interest and
the first censorship was on dudes that
were
screaming at george bush saying that he
was a child
effort and a goat effort it was that
that guy philip warren he was the first
internet censored guy and he was
probably censored on in the right
because he was aggro as f
um you know that is a very vague term
you can you can be agro independent
media you can be
creative independent media i think aggro
stuff tends to get banned though it's
it's it really is a bias against the
right
and i think it's hilarious um
that it's obvious if you take an
objective view on what's going on look
at parlor
just totally wiped out it's gone
it's obvious you know you look at the
the channels that are allowed
to be on youtube they get promoted
establishment channels of course are
protected
but then you look at left-wing channels
where they're talking about russia
and supporting these unhinged theories
and there's been
no there's there's been no
reconciliation there's been no justice
there's been no
fairness in any of the policies put
forth by these platforms
it's like i was saying yesterday jack
dorsey is in a far left bubble he can't
see out of
to him all of these things are normal so
when he sees a regular working class
you know 45 year old guy tweet something
about learning the code he goes an
extremist
delete not realizing most americans have
no idea what you're talking about
but they're getting nuked these these
platforms are controlled by you know
one of a large portion for the most part
of these ideological tribes
youtube seems to be this is surprising
it's bad there's a lot of problems with
youtube and censorship way better than
twitch for instance
twitch will ban you in two seconds for
giving a conservative opinion because
their their user base is too
left and then you have twitter which is
very left facebook
which is interesting this is interesting
i
i used to upload my videos to facebook
and i stopped last week when they
restricted my page
for covering what happened at the
capitol that's it
and people were like i had people even
commenting saying all i did was say
here's what's happening here's a tweet
here's what's happening here's the
response
gone yep i have a telegram page with 5
000 subscribers
and then i have a facebook page with 600
000 subscribers that that was like that
for a number of years now
i get more web traffic and reach through
the 5 000 group on telegram
than the 600 000 group on facebook
that's why we're telling everybody to go
to timcast.com and become a member
because i fully expect look my facebook
page it's over
now i can still post to it but there's
no point the the
the posts are all restricted they've
stripped me from monetization which i
wasn't really getting in the first place
so i didn't care all that much when it
happened
but it shows you the cliffs are once
again eroding it's only a matter of time
before they come and say oh you you're
you're telling people to calm down
look we'll get to a point where they'll
say their fight is righteous
and and you know defending these people
means you're you're either with us or
against us and so by by defending people
by saying don't fight you're defending
them therefore you're banned we'll get
to that point
it'll happen and i don't know when but i
imagine it'll happen soon the first
thing they're trying to do is get rid of
all as many voices as possible
because they only want approved channels
youtube's wanted to be netflix for a
long time
they don't like the idea that anybody
can start a channel and just share
things they don't like the you in
youtube
but they want to maintain the user base
which they have so that's where we're
headed
so yes go to timcast.com become a member
if you want to help
protect us in the event that they they
nuke the the uh the platform
uh it's possible and we're trying really
hard to get like a core
dedicated user base to subscribe and
then we'll put up more and more you
you know member-only content stuff like
that but i really i really do
hope things that you know things get
chilled out steve you remember
you were mentioning that you guys don't
use social media is there a reason
yeah it's uh well as an
organization again we have no acts to
grind
there's no benefit for us
in that manner we people who come to us
already have a minds the mindset that
matters
is to have a mindset to be prepared and
that mindset is more important
than uh commenting on
all these things that are just going to
come and go
on social media what um you mentioned
your organization
like of the organization top down
so drew miller is the ceo
i am the coo then each of the ranches
have ranch
managers and assistant ranch managers
we are veteran owned and operated so we
only hire former vets or former law
enforcement
we actually have two openings we have
we're in need of a ranch man
manager out for the colorado branch and
i'm in need of a assistant
wrench manager out in west virginia
because we keep moving staff around as
we expand so you have the manager the
assistant manager and then how many
people
potentially would have like spots at a
ranch
so we don't give out exact numbers for
security reasons but
each ranch you know will round out
around 100
until we would expand more but we try
not to we don't want to expand
make any one ranch too large we're
looking for 12 across the country so
that nobody has to drive too far in case
of an instant event and that's because
and it helps to keep it small for like
one manager and assistant to take care
of any potential conflict or
struggle that would arise right so just
the idea you just
keep building more staff and staff and
staff to be able to do this properly
and then you need more resources more
more resources more resources
so there's a there's an equation there
that we look at
as what would be best fit for that
location
and then we spread that out what do the
manager and the assistant manager do
so uh well there's there's so much
maintenance
expansion you know i don't do any of the
sales or anything along that lines we
have a
sales crew but i do do the tours
and i do the vetting prospective members
and then when members come out to use
their free days then i'm available to
them to do training
uh to help them what kind of training
a lot of the time it's with firearms
because we have to make sure that
we won't allow anybody to pull guard
duty in a
crisis or a collapse situation unless
they've been approved
that that assistant manager position
looks pretty tempting i should talk to
you about
potentially filling in that need after
the show
everybody else stay away so
in the event of let's let's say there's
a national
crisis and deeply affects the economy
and people's ability to survive
so they all come in how does that
structure work i mean are you guys the
boss
will you tell people yes so they have a
membership
agreement that they read in sign
which informed them informs them
of the standard operating procedures to
a certain degree
but the main point is we are in charge
so let's say
uh food is in short supply but you guys
have you're stocked up for a very very
long time
well the key to sustainability is not
having a warehouse full of food
but having your own ecosystem so we have
cattle goats
chickens we have not only our 114 acres
to hunt on but we have the national
forest that abuts us which is another
1 800 acres to hunt deer beer
turkey grouse and we have a
stream right across the road we have
really good fishing in west virginia
there's only one natural sand beach
and we're not located too far from there
it's the stock so well so what happens
if uh
there's total collapse people can't pay
their membership anymore right
right so now it's just what start
working start farming
there's going to be plenty to do
actually there'll be a lot to do
initially
and people tend to be out of shape these
days so
uh i don't know that ripped real quick
yeah i don't know how much work i'll get
out of them right in the beginning you
know
do you have horses really quick sorry uh
we do not on property but we do have
horses i'd imagine that the kind of
people you'd attract would
they understand that if you know if it
hits the fan
they're going to start working harder
than they've worked probably i have i
look them in the eye
and i i explain what the situation is in
order for this to work
everybody has to pull their own weight i
got i got to ask you this question the
audience has probably heard me talk
about this before but during occupy wall
street
farmland was donated to the activists
i knew several activists who said that
they didn't want to
live in these cities and they wanted to
go live on the farm and be sustainable
how long do you think they lasted after
they went to their farm
no idea wild guess how how long do you
think they were there before they said
you know
a month two weeks oh two weeks
and uh you know the people who came back
my friends were like
i would wake up at 6 a.m and work until
midnight and go to bed and wake up at 6
a.m and work until it's not non-stop
no chance to read no tv nothing it was
literally just tiny to the animals it
was farming it was endless work
and i'm like yeah that's called living
sustainably
absolutely you want to live in luxury in
these cities sure
it's not so easy when you're responsible
for for everything right and there's not
only
you know so we have you know
hundreds of thousands of seeds to be
able to grow each season and then
as you do that gardening then you also
dry the seeds of the
those things that you have raised and so
you just have a continual
cycle we don't have to worry about
relying on electricity
all of our everything is on grid but we
have
solar on each of the ranches
that would kick on automatically if we
ever lose
energy and then the main fuel when you
look to prepare
for the worst is you need plenty of wood
because that's going to be your fuel for
heating
every single uh building
has a wood stove and it's flat top so
that you can cook on it you have to
think these things
through in order for this to wow now
here's the
the tough question you might not be able
to answer let's say the collapse happens
and all your members come in but then
you see one day
you know you guys are working you're
tending to your animals a couple
families
just look really really hungry and
desperate come up and they say we
you have to let us in do you let them in
no
no but what if they what i don't let my
kids in they're not members
only members what do you do when a group
of people come and they're they're
they're they're yelling
we're gonna die you have to let us in
what happens if they
try and run in what happens if they have
weapons well
we have more but there's your answer
no and i i i'm joking
it depends on it depends on the
circumstances
yeah um safety would be a priority for
those who are members
now as under a crisis situation you
would
you could approach the ranch but you'll
have
you'll meet the initial guard post and
our members have to get out and identify
themselves
and those are the only people that are
on the list
are allowed in now depending on the
circumstances as
things go and we have an abundance of
food there isn't an epidemic
i don't want to sound heartless and
cruel
but that is the rule i mean i literally
when i took the position told my kids
you know either sign up
they'll come me and tim have screaming
arguments about
a strategy here that maybe you could
help us settle okay
because i know an amazing community with
special forces green berets
preppers homeschoolers up in new
hampshire and i saw a plot of property
open up i'm like tim
maybe this is something you should look
at he's like hell no
i rather go to the middle of montana and
and i
said west virginia what are you talking
about well west virginia but also you
made a statement about going in the
middle of montana
uh and i'm like you would look like a
straw man argument
and you would well the argument is west
virginia or new hampshire here we go we
get very tense when we argue about
now i'll tell you right away he's
already on my side he's in west virginia
well if you if you have a community of
of of like-minded good people would you
rather have would you rather be on your
own and look like a filet mignon steak
to a whole bunch of crazy hungry wolves
in the wild and not knowing anyone in
west virginia
or would you rather be or would you
rather
or would you rather have a good
community of people okay hold on let me
start over
the actual question is is new hampshire
a better place
than west virginia when it comes it's
not about the state
it it's all about location location
location wherever it may be
if it has a fresh source of water
it it has timberland all around it so
that you can hunt
use the wood if it has the ability
to have natural protection then
you could do it anywhere what would you
do natural protection
so we're surrounded by mountain ranges
all around us
uh same thing in colorado nevada's off
and you're on the high ground
and we're on the high ground that
natural protection being protected from
humans
well not only but you do want it to be
defensible um
because coming over the ridges on all
around us is
is virtually impossible uh certain not
in mass
for sure so my my my art my position you
know luke
is defending new hampshire but my que my
issue is the
you know the northeast population
density is substantially higher than
west virginia
yes which which can be a risk but you
know so
so for us as a model we're actually
located two out
two hours outside of a major city is the
only way that it works
in order to um and again but the
location has to be right
but part of the reason is there's no way
you know part of our job is to help
folks
so we we have to be in a place where
they can get to
you have to have a market um for those
who are going to be the most affected
and obviously it's the cities that are
going to be
most effective that's 100 that's where
it starts that's where it bubbles over
i mean it all goes from there and the
suburbs aren't much safer you still
can't do much if you're in the suburbs
well another important point you don't
want to be moving around when hit
when right when ish hits the fan family
friendly show
so that's the way you phrased that yeah
it hits the fan yeah yeah uh
uh i was i was talking to some people
who live out in more rural areas
they were telling me that when the
covert thing happened nothing changed
for them
my life hasn't been affected one bit
yeah not one bit
i mean other than me having a mask in my
truck for when i
go to the store you know go pick up
supplies at home depot
for you know things that we're doing i i
don't know anyone who's caught it i
i west virginia was the last state
to have the first kit you know the first
ones to have any and it's really not
disrupted
you know disrupted my life regarding
crops um like in
right now are you guys growing crops or
is it only like we have seeds
and we will start growing if so we have
five acres we use for hay
to be able to feed the animal we so in
order for me not to
just be a farmer right now before
anything happens
we have 20 head of cattle on reserve
there's nothing around us but chicken
farms and
cattle farms and so we have a deal with
the
local farmer he comes and uh he
in the spring he you know spreads the
manure he cuts it he bails it he leaves
me what i need for the animals that i
have and he takes the rest
to augment is he de facto part of the
community uh
no he actually he's pretty well set up
where he is a lot of people in west
virginia are
yeah if something really bad happens
these cities i think
it was drew miller who's had something
72 hours to animal yeah
oh it yeah when it ignites again and
that's why i'm saying
when all those pieces are in place when
it does go up it
it that did the tapping
i was warned people but uh when it
happens
yes when all the right pieces aren't
what 72 hours to animals
what do you think's going to happen to
new york city in three days oh they'll
start eating each other
yeah yeah yeah that kind of animal i see
yeah yeah i just had a couple come down
last weekend from manhattan
they're they're running from new york
they bought land in
uh another state but they joined uh
because of
my ranch because it's so the uh
you're also selling plots yes and we
also so we actually have rv
um we expanded oh uh our rv
i am looking for employment we
so we have you know we have we're always
looking on how best to serve
folks and earlier there wasn't a large
demand for the rvs but now there is
after all that's been going on yeah
so i had an excavation crew in there and
and uh we've
we've done a lot of excavation to expand
the rv situation and
we've already sold a couple of three
acre plots of land where people are
going to
uh build their own uh little
log home or whatever they're going to
build on the property but still be part
of the community wow dome maybe we've
been looking at building domes you ever
check out geodesic domes oh i have heard
of them well so
we're located right near the i mean
we're literally
right we got ridges all around us so the
most affordable way is you just dig
in too and all that land that you're
taking out of there
to build your foundation you put up here
to give you a level space where you
build
and cool so you can actually have your
own you know small little bunker as you
drive in you already have some
hardened security and then you go up to
your home yeah and then you have a guard
force all around putting like shipping
contain burying shipping containers and
using those
yeah cool the domes i think is a fun
idea because it's like cheap
and they're super structurally sound
right and we could build it
we don't need a professional architect
it's just like
a little hippie bolting down yeah
there's a reason hippies oh absolutely
if hippies could do them
we are hippies we do all our own
construction you know we keep our
our costs down that way right on well
let's go to super chats see what the uh
probably a lot of questions for you from
the audience so we'll go through them if
you haven't already smash the like
button subscribe
the notification bell and become a
member at timcast.com because we have a
ton of fun bonus segments coming up
probably some gun stuff i'd imagine at
some point because you know luke likes
guns
we should make a trip this weekend uh
we'll talk about that
we'll talk about that off the show yeah
we'll make a video this weekend uh so
yeah go to timecast.com but uh let's uh
let's read the super chats
johnny knoxville who i i don't think is
the real genuine film would like us to
know that he's naked
thank you for the super chat i
appreciate you giving me two dollars to
let us know that
you said live free and prosperous that's
right jonathan
galterini says that judge prescott and
the what is it elaine
delaney hearing orders the unsealing of
more documents more documents to come
that'll be interesting i'm keeping a
very close eye on that situation
c miller says leftovers from yesterday i
also have a smith and wesson victory
a lot of 22 pistols get failure to eject
because they have stiff recoil springs
use cci high velocity in all 22
semi-autos works like a charm
that's a that's that was a problem we
had we were taking the victory to the
range
and it wasn't ejecting properly so i was
getting jammed it's annoying
probably lost some a ton of good 22 that
way
redacted says me and the boys updating
our twitter bios to add
resist not my president after tomorrow
night
the new resistance is here yes can we
can we take back resistance yes again
jos batali says have any of you seen the
anime fully [ __ ]
spoilers it ends with a giant weapon
used to iron out the wrinkles in your
brain so you can't think
yeah oh it's a it's a great show it's
only i think what six episodes or is it
four episodes six i think it's six short
shorts yeah and then they tried doing a
sequel which was kind of just derivative
and i know this is so dumb
dan n says we are in canada watching
your country biting our fingernails
geez you know what's fun about canada
poutine
delicious oh and then but fresh curd
cheese yeah
but i went to a poutine restaurant and
it's not just curds and gravy
they had all different kinds it's
amazing yeah i used to work at a french
canadian
so we ordered like three different kinds
and i'm like that's a lot of potato
yeah we're all canucks up there in new
hampshire we love it
graeme wilson says recently you've made
a few statements on what you believe
national guardsman reactions would be in
regards to everything that is happening
i'm a filmmaker and former national
guardsman of 12 years
and i'd love to help inform hit me up
can i talk about this real fast cause i
actually asked a couple of my sources i
was like what is the morale level
there in dc and the response that i got
was they're just confused they don't
really know why they're there
and they don't really know what's going
on and i was like yeah it's consistent
with what every single person did they
get called up like were they in the
reserve and they were just all
stood down and they got called up i
believe so i read it was from all 50
states as well yeah
we got one for luke bruce the boss
brooks says luke i'm waiting for that
how many lick
and fraudulent slip t-shirt ah
yeah that's great ideas i've gotten like
a hundred emails
from people about alternatives thank you
guys
so much so so far all the stuff you know
all the shirts are still on we are
changing or slash shirts but if that
changes
it's still going to be the same url but
i'm looking at changing and
thank you really great advice well let's
see
kowi writer says tell the truth he
really works for vault-tec
so you're familiar with fallout i am i
am so uh your facility which experiment
are you running on your
i'm just going to well freeze so for
those that aren't familiar with the
fallout series
there was a bunch of vaults made by the
vault-tec corporation and the government
but they were actually running
experiments on the people who were
seeking shelter
some of them were some voters well there
were specifically four experiments
actually yeah but i think there was only
like one
no no there was there was some that were
legitimate shelters but a lot of them
were doing experiments
there was uh i think it was vault 69 was
99 men and one woman i think it was or
no
was that wasn't 99 women and one man i
don't know probably that
and then there was one where they use
the forced evolutionary virus on people
and turn them into mutants
fallout's fun game vaults are cool do
you guys build vaults is that stuff you
even talk about publicly like your
underground network well
it's eight inches of reinforced concrete
covered with steel plating
three foot of earth wait wait you
actually have those yeah
wow 120 foot long one of them do you
ever do like tours of them or do you
keep them yeah
oh that'd be cool we do like that you
would post online
no oh okay yeah top secret and the
locations are secret too aren't they
wow that's rad cool cool stuff let's see
we got here daniel maxwell says
if what is happening to the national
guard personnel right now
does not set off warning alarms then you
need a very close look at what happened
in germany when hitler took over
in russia under stalin and in china
under mao repeating history again
you know i think what happens is these
people in power are scared they're
losing the confidence
of the people and that's all government
is
if people have no confidence in you
they're not going to listen i will say i
like that phrase repeating history
again well they say history doesn't
repeat itself but it rhymes
alberto rio says i understand that uh i
understand this is a little late
since this is more of a question that
should have been asked in your last show
have any of these business owners looked
into 18 usc 242
when fighting these unconstitutional
orders from governors we'll have to ask
them
next time i suppose caper 2x says when
the saucers land on the mall
we will wish for more troops and forget
what we do if they demand to cook and
eat our leaders
wait so that's why trump is leaving
early lol yes
the aliens are coming we get to the cia
segment but you know whatever
the wolf shark says y'all might be
interested in contacting gary anderson
for the show
he is the cop that got fired from from
portland for speaking against lockdowns
a few months ago and started the podcast
endless endeavor oh yeah oh that's cool
writing this down
um you you're gonna love this one larry
goddard says you're heisenberg
have you heard that one before when i
was in belarus i was linen
[Laughter]
ian hall says ah s get your tim foil
hats here
released from the lab look at patents
michael dodson says my girlfriend works
in healthcare
and they received an email today telling
them to be prepared for curfews
and to pack go bags to last multiple
days they're located well
outside the dc beltway interesting
hyperbole
count ludwig says police state is here
as a historian i think that peaceful
secession of liberty-minded states
probably only way out of tyranny or
civil war
it can be done norway seceded from
sweden peacefully in the early 1900s
really i didn't know that that was one
two different countries
petty says tim i will buy all of your
nine by 18. there's nothing on shelves
for my pmm down here
no way i just someone sent me an email
for a czechoslovakian gun
and i got it ordered so my snap
previously useless makarov nine
millimeter will be fun
you get more of that makarov non
millimeter i don't think so
really i just i i i remember what
happened but i was not paying attention
and i just bought a bunch
and the and and the dudes were cool
about it they were like we get it you
probably made a mistake most people
don't realize this i was like i'm
keeping it
more valuable than the
yeah dude i'm seeing it's barter for the
future yeah
well that's why i like common calibers
and common guns like glocks because
everyone has them there's a lot of them
there's a lot of pieces anything goes
wrong you'll be able to fix it you'll be
able to trade it
and all the custom customizable parts
are very
cheap compared to the rarer guns oh it's
interesting uh so
continuing from the comment about norway
count lunwick ludwig says and some of
the nations in the ussr such as
such as estonia and latvia gained their
freedom in 1989 by literally holding
hands and singing songs
just a few years ago scotland almost
left the uk by voting
that's right singing revolution in
estonia i mean honestly
i really do think we're at a point in in
history
that if say texas or california voted
outright overwhelmingly within their
state to secede
the u.s would do nothing there would be
no way yep do not be surrounded by
federal troops it'd be invaded in every
corner
they'd have their powers shut off they'd
have their problems scotland was
conquered
and they're voting texas the largest
military base in the free world
san diego three divisions there's
the naval base in san diego they
wouldn't let that go it's two
what would they do fortresses of san
francisco what would they
invade it they would massacre the
leadership and put new leadership in
then why is scotland allowed to have
these referendums scottish part of the
british empire
they haven't left and if they tried we
probably would have saw a conflict
what do you mean they're voting on it
they they're talking about doing it now
there's memes about scotland wanting to
leave the uk but join the eu let's wait
and see
us is the most militarized country in
the world i cannot fathom them letting
go of their
of their resources right now yeah but i
just think we're
we're we're well beyond the point where
people
support that kind of action it was easy
to do back in the day when no one knew
about it but do you support 25 000
troops in dc no who does exactly yeah
but they're doing it anyway but it's
causing problems
of course you see it's it's actually
people are talking about how it's going
to be weak
and it's worrying it's a there's a lack
of confidence in what they're doing
they're trying to make people think
they're strong that's scary
smash that like button if you haven't
already and let's read some more super
chats
cheerful all right let's see we got here
control alt right says no you can't see
and see a gun
cheap or easy coming from a guy who
knows interesting
mad says hey tim a few weeks ago my
uncle and i were talking about the proud
boys
15 minutes later he asked if i was a
proud boy joking jokingly i responded oh
for sure
then my headphones siri said i figured i
threw my phone
that's weird that's weird anthony pikas
says there is no issue with creating a
gun with no serial number
it just has to be serialized before you
sell it to someone else oh
yeah a bunch of people are saying this
ed mazzett says ghost guns are legal
also
you guys are horribly outdated on your
3d printed gun knowledge look up the fg
c9 you want to look that up fg c9
i write that down nice
ryan berkel says weird boys podcast on
youtube and facebook we will talk
anything paranoid paranormal cryptid and
most conspiracy you guys rock appreciate
it
we'll get more into that as we're
getting away from you know we'll see how
things go with politics but uh we'll get
more into it
gareth green says i grew up on the
religious right and i thought the
democrats were the enemy in the 90s
interesting helpless gazelle says i'm a
veteran with the gadsden flag on my
backpack
am i a threat now i served my country
honorably some states even offer it as a
license plate
that's crazy you can get the gadsden
flag on your license plate when you go
and you say i'll take that one
yep and now they're saying that's a sign
of you that's crazy
john hutto says you can make a gun
without a serial number but you cannot
transfer it to anyone
it is yours and yours alone forever
can't even have someone repair it for
you
liberator has many design iterations
that have improved in many ways
interesting yeah another person mentions
george pumphrey says control
is over fgc9 with a simple 3d printer
i'm looking at fgc 9 it actually stands
for
uh f gun control f as in fornicating
under the
incentive um and
it's it looks pretty serious the barrel
looks
metallic but um there's different
variations there's also it looks like
nails
metal nails that that are commonly used
that you could use so it's it's it's a
counterpart but i'm reading up on this i
read very interesting
i think yeah you still need like a metal
barrel yeah yeah that's
that's what this model that i'm looking
at uh i think has
yeah specifically in there what's up so
that's what it's a carbine it's a
carbine what does that mean
well well it's like a specific um
you know like a smaller firearm um
i don't know how how would you describe
it it's a classification yeah
does it mean it's smaller than a normal
type of weapon of that type no i mean
i can look it up but it's a
semi-automatic pistol caliber carbine
the f's gc20 i'm sure someone will super
chat us giving us the breakdown of what
a carbine is yeah
i'm i'm not a gun expert by any stretch
of the imagination so i'm not even going
to try
fuba do say fubuda that's a good name
says ghost guns are in fact legal
federally
check state laws some do ban them search
for deterrence dispensed
to find out more about 3d printed guns
they have advanced quite a bit
and last thousands of rounds really
that's crazy
yeah i mean i remember the defense
distributed stuff years ago so i'm
definitely outdated on all that stuff
this says carbine is a short barreled
rifle
do you have 3d printers at uh in your
facilities no
i think you should get them i think you
know like it's you can print like really
simple thing like knobs and hinges
maybe like missing parts for something
something breaks repairs so it's pretty
handy
pretty easy stuff although i guess you
need someone to be able to do like the
cad stuff right
like 3d printing yeah kind of but once
you figure it out it's actually very
simple
yeah download a file hit go yeah
maybe you need a nozzle or some kind of
you know component that
isn't made anymore mark wolff says this
practice of rhetoric is old and reliable
sadly we haven't changed much much
aristo wise uh
aristo wisely defined rhetoric to be a
science to persuade the people
socrates and plato and art to flatter
and deceive
interesting gareth green says remember
when they called benghazi a partisan
witch hunt
oh yeah archangel says i got banned on
twitter for sharing video of democrats
calling for more riots
said it was for posting spam you know
there you go
keith reyes says tim it is 100 legal to
build it build a non-serial
firearm hence 80 lowers for ar-15s and
polymer 80 builds for glock sig style
pistols
what is illegal is for a person a person
to sell a non-serial
firearm that's really crazy we've got 3d
printers are we really
well we'll look into this and make sure
we want we need a metal 3d printer
though
but that's that's metal that's like an
industrial thing right that'd be a big
one printing molten steel or something
or molten metals
all right then i don't know about that
maybe a cnc machine
yeah i've i i knew a dude who had a big
one it was cool he would he was pretty
he would print rocket parts you'd watch
it like cut through the metal and stuff
was awesome nice
yeah and then you'd be like look i made
rocket parts we're like just in the
other room
yep wow that's cool yeah
all right let's see we got here kiwi two
one one three says i just watched your
interview with david pakman from a year
ago
and i'm curious about how much both of
your opinions have evolved since then
that was from longer than a year ago i'm
pretty sure wasn't it like two or three
years ago
at this point i don't know i don't i
don't i don't know either we'll uh
someone i have no idea maybe maybe we'll
have another one in the future
booker dewitt catch says tim and
actually anyone that has a joke by the
way i wonder how many people got it
and actually anyone there i know this is
off topic but would you mind explaining
gamergate
maybe just a quick explanation i have a
hard time understanding it and
no it can't be done it just you can't it
was uh
no developers no we're get got woke
there you go it's so much it's it but
that's that's not fair it's not
you can't do it justice you can't
because it's not about that
it's about collusion corruption right
right
they were paying companies to write
articles
for to make positive games no no it's
more complicated than that yep
advertisers would buy an ad on a website
the website would review their the
company's games but
lie and say they were good games because
otherwise they would lose sponsorship
that's only like point one percent of
what was going on so you can't even get
into it
vanessa aponte says deep state probably
told trump if you even try pardoning
assange you'll be hanging with jfk
well the the what i'm hearing is that
republicans in the senate said
we'll convict you so you better not
pardon assange and trump said okay
and they're going to convict him anyway
oh just like that 2 000 scandal that
again
trump promised he was going to give
everyone and then then
all the representatives said no no no
we're going to do it a different way he
got screwed that
way then we got screwed the republicans
don't want trump running again
so the republicans will be like i guess
we have to convict
and then trump will be able to run
because they'll have gotten him on
insurrection
which then the 14th amendment i believe
it's article 3 or whatever says you
cannot
run for office or hold office if you've
ever in inside an insurrection against
the country
also i'm looking at the fgc 9
part list there's a lot of metal parts
there's a lot of building it's not just
press print and go it seems a lot more
complicated but thank you for that
informative super chat um
it definitely um you know
made me aware of it gunner anderson says
luckily i run my eight i run aks my
4.5 uh by 39 millimeter and 762 by 39
are readily available and still around
35 cents a round
kalash life there's a lot of stuff you
go to the store and they have like uh 40
caliber and uh what's another like they
have a
10 millimeter i'll get some nine
millimeter today which i'm very happy
about but it all depends on the location
like in new hampshire
380 was readily available now here
uh undisclosed location middle america
it's not as readily available so it all
depends
and yeah kalashnikovs i love aks they're
my favorite
even though ar is a little bit more
practical and useful jacob brownfield
to the rescue long arm in pistol
cartridge
carbine there you go oh that's simple
crazy larry says i bought a camper for
starting off-grid lifestyle before covet
hit
been prepping with dehydrator vacuum
sealer ready to work will be emailing
soon first super chat long time
love of the show yeah so it's uh it's
fortituderanch.com
yeah people should check it out but
we'll we'll do another round of of
promoting it too once we get through
some more super chats and
start winding down justin edelson says
look at spain they didn't allow
catalan to leave that's true they
definitely they went in and the cops
but it wasn't the cops were just beating
people you know i was there actually
when they did that a couple years ago
and they were doing that vote and the
cops were just beating people the
barcelonan police do not play around
they are vicious i remember covering
them as well they sent in
police from madrid yeah because
barcelona the cops were loyal to
you know catalonia well the the
repression down there was crazy and this
is the event that led
julian assange to losing his internet
because he actually promoted the
independence of catalan
here's this is interesting freedom
thought says uh three percenters sent an
email telling people not to go to the
capitol protests calling for peace and
logical action
then their website was removed that's
what i'm saying about people saying
don't do it
they're gonna take you out yeah a lot of
people are saying as i mentioned
yesterday
don't go to washington dc it's a trap
there's there's going to be some kind of
bigger possible action just stay away
jd zapp says love the show did any of
you guys see the video of a strange
light floating and flying around the
capitol buildings in dc last night what
no but i want to i've been reading about
ball lightning
you guys familiar with that phenomenon
apparently when lightning strikes it can
create a
sphere of they don't know what light or
plasma or something that can contain
material and pass
through walls and like it's a ball
lightning it's just it can go through i
mean
my friend jeremy risk said that it can
go through solids like windows but
windows are actually
liquid glass is a form of liquid so
maybe that's why it can pass through
liquid oh
no it can contain a piece of sand and
move it through glass
who's your film says what is the mayans
uh the mayans were dyslexic and the end
of the world is 2021 not 2012.
yeah it could be yeah i've heard that
not elferia says in fallout the vaults
worked
as advertised were the control group so
they were still part of the experiment
oh there you go i guess uh yeah yeah so
the
the ones where people got to live normal
lives well that was the control but who
was monitoring the experiments the
enclave
i think was the enclave right i suppose
maybe
now we're getting a lot of fallout
comments
gabriel logan says tim it's extremely
disrespectful to talk about mangled
bodies around a combat veteran it's
different for us we couldn't leave when
we wanted to
and that could be us the next day would
you
would you agree absolutely yeah yeah
gunner jones says hey tim i got fired
today from my job because i was watching
your videos and they said i was watching
racist videos at work
i don't know if i believe that to be
honest because what what would the video
have been about
we were talking about race yesterday
which is technically racist
i mean they think they think
everything's racist tell them they're
racist because this is a minority-owned
company in a minority-led
show correct so how dare they racial
genius ginger says a carbine is a rifle
that fires a lighter caliber like a 40
smith and wesson nine millimeter or a
five five six two two three
not an sbr x says cheap metal printer
the iro 3d we should get one of those
really
iro 3d william monroy says for metal
look into lost pla casting cool
avinav rao says hey tim appreciate the
consistent quality content you and your
team are putting out simply put
are we now living in ccp america
close to it almost yeah i mean they're
running concentration camps and trying
to take over
taiwan and hong kong and hong kong's
falling so they have a social credit
score which of course many corporations
in the united states built
for them people forget china is as
powerful as it is mainly because of the
kissinger
doctrine and american elites that are
still propping it up
so yeah elite machine works says hey tim
if you are looking for someone with cnc
machines and 3d printers i'd love to
talk
willing to relocate my cnc shop to small
community and contribute
i design and produce 3d printers all
in-house
oh that's really cool cool stuff pablia
says
go to ivan the trolls twitter and check
out his link in bio
i don't know what that would be reese
ward says if you don't have ammo
you are left with an expensive club
reminds me of uh the movie snatch you
ever guys see
you ever see that the dude's buying the
revolver and he's like it's kind of
heavy and he goes heavy is good
if it doesn't work you hit them with it
and then
and then later on he finds out it's a
bad gun it doesn't work good stuff
archangel 978 says please get on
demolition ranch you will learn so much
plus the guy rules demolition ranch is
awesome yeah i'd love to have mine
that'd be fun
um those videos are so great we should
we should do a compliment we should do a
video with him
uh here and it would be it's really
really fun well he's a huge
channel he makes awesome stuff yeah i
enjoyed that
yeah yeah i was was i watching i think i
was watching him do a full
full auto uh 50 caliber rifle
we should get one of those versions yeah
but there's a lot there's like a lot of
things like you have to do to be able to
not full auto but just a 50 cal would be
really nice
oh yeah you know that's necessary we
have one at each range yeah it's not
asking for too much just one
well they're great for vehicles i mean
uh yeah
anything up armored i mean you know but
are you are you allowed to discuss
i guess even on the surface the kind of
uh defensive capabilities you have
like do you have things above 50
are you allowed to say no so 50 is like
yeah
top tier no no no battleships hidden
anywhere
artillery howitzers or something cannons
i have a flamethrower that i own legally
lasers
yeah what about lasers that's short
range i think uh i wonder if you guys uh
uh
you know directed energy weapons
anything like that
here's what here's what i'm thinking you
know what uh active denial systems are
yeah you need some of those huh put them
up in the perimeter when it gets bad and
people just walk up and walk right back
all of that takes energy yep yep i
bought something a lot so
that's the problem this is what people
don't understand about
you know lasers and directed energy
weapons is that the amount of energy
conversion
to hurt someone with direct energy is a
lot more
than to push a piece of metal through a
tube ballistics
is incredible even in space ballistics
is an incredible weapon because if you
puncture
the hall of a ship i mean that's it i
mean lasers have their place
and um like uh you you watch the the
targeting they do at the infrared lasers
on drones
it just tracks perfectly and just takes
it out there's no missing
but when it comes to like standard
combat
guns are pretty efficient you don't want
to go too high-tech
right you really don't i mean not for
the long-term sustainability model that
really is the only one that'll work but
i think you'd be able to get off um you
know motion sensor
activated active denial system for
perimeter defense that would be pretty
low energy
because it wouldn't really ever be on
you know just be there and then it would
flick on and flick off and people would
just immediately go the other direction
you know right it would i mean it would
have to have its own power source
yeah they'd have to be linked and they
have to be some kind of you know
yeah source of energy to tap into do you
guys use ham radios we do
every ranch has ham radio i was looking
at tam radios today i kind of want to
get one
no no have you have you created like um
what is it bonded ham internet no that's
that's something that's you can create a
loc
there's probably people who are
listening who know better than i do but
i was reading about
low quality internet you can get using
ham bonding frequencies and then
actually transmit data
and be able to hear that it's illegal to
encrypt anything over ham radio right
now yeah i don't know if that's true but
that was reading that cam's cool
cool stuff radio is great all right
let's see we got here
we got we got a couple uh let's do uh
okay i read that one already madgal
mad gal design co says boy it feels like
a countdown to what i don't know i just
want to live
normally again it feels like it will
never be the same again amen
yeah what do you think about that it's
not going to be the same again
yeah i i've seen people saying that dc
will never go back to normal
why why why would they give up the power
they can they've locked down the whole
jurisdiction why give it up
we've we've trampled over so many
precedences there's
there's a lot of things that there's no
going back to
donald c says metal 3d printers use a
layer to scan and selectively melt
metal powder particles bonding them
together and building a part layer by
layer
i've seen that have you guys ever seen
that no that's crazy not in first
yeah it's like it reminds me of mission
impossible when they make those masks
and the laser like comes down and just
makes it
that's cool i've done it with gel with
like um
resin where it'll use a uv light to
harden the resin and it pulls it out
of the goo but i haven't done it with
metal yet
blank says hey tim look up the story of
nazinski infinitely
known as stalin's cannibal island a
gulag
so bad it's it turns the stomach uh
it it it turned the stomach of soviet
elites evil
is the real uh israel the horror so
where they put people in the gulag and
they start eating each other
that sounds crazy what else are you
gonna do if there's no food i mean
yeah carl flynn says have you gotten the
chance to watch run hide fight
i was kind of skeptical at first but i
have to admit i was very i was pleased i
was very pleasantly surprised very well
done
yeah the trailer looked really good yeah
garrett gareth green says gamergate sjw
indie text game developer
cheats on her boyfriend with gaming
journalist
who just so happened to have promoted
set designer in articles and boyfriend's
heartbreak
blog goes mega viral oh there you go
ag says tim why did you skip my super
chat about turkey and azerbaijan
ethnically cleansing armenians from
art sock have you been paid off by turk
pr firms
no i've actually skipped quite a bit of
super chats because we can only read so
many i'll vouch for it
mason perry says there are long rifles
short rifles and carbines
caliber is not a factor in
classification interesting
all right sane says as a retired staff
sergeant i want to know how they're
vetting the troops in dc
are they threat uh threatening
threatening them with
threatening them with prison if they
don't and uh don't swear loyalty to
biden
no they're just like you posted about
the nra so you gotta go
stupid too curtis mayer says tim and
crew you guys rock
ian it's taken me a few months to
understand you but i really enjoy your
mind and how you see the world thank you
curtis
you're not alone
all right let's see d.a says can you
talk about
the crypto frt and what its purpose is
i can't i don't know what that is fart
rt let's find out fart or fort
huh or frank i've never heard of it yeah
let's see i can't how do i pronounce
your name k uh kalid
oh gosh name i am an inventor and use 3d
printing to prototype would be happy to
come give a workshop that'd be fun
i'm really interested in that metal 3d
printing thing with a yeah metal grain
and a laser to weld
each layer of grain that's that's
amazing
that's cool stuff nicolas munoz says any
of those great ranches based in
california
no nevada would be the closest one at
this time
why would you want to be in california
is the question
the fault lines and communism fault
lines are crazy dude my whole life was
changed when i lived in l.a like
you can't put anything above your head
of course when you're sleeping
and now you can you know now that i'm
not
dreaded moonpie says the more i watch
this show the more i crush on luke
image thank you image.jpg says ham up
here
i'd like to share any info 100 watts
from ia got me to russia and new zealand
you cannot encrypt data on ham
frequencies interesting
mr verdict says you guys have to be
absolutely raking in the super chats
too bad it's not in bitcoin i know
i remember when bitcoin was at 30 it was
like 38 or something
and then people were like oh it's too
high and the news came out and said oh
it's going to tank
drops down to 30. and i see i see people
tweeting i'm going to sell now
and then buy back at the bottom and i'm
like okay you're making a mistake
and then boom right back up to 35.
bitcoin is going to go up up up man
charles baylosian says my girlfriend
thinks i called you out for not loving
armenia wasn't me
well there you go jq nelson film says
tim did you see the black lives matter
twerk for mlk video
you can't make this stuff up it was
released by the official blm
organization yeah it's not the first
time they've done it
they did it in 2014 and i don't care
i don't know luke mentioned it i was
like they're spending their 10.6 billion
dollars on efforts to shake their
potonkadonks
in celebration and what if it's just
it's just weird it's just
i don't think so it's not the way to
kind of memorialize a religious pastor
i disagree um well i think he would
disagree i think he would be kind of
disappointed by that
especially you know i think the person i
think if somebody
likes dancing a specific way and you
don't like the way they dance it's
all about it i'm all for personal
freedom i don't think it's weird for me
it was just a little
you know kind of distasteful in my
opinion yeah but it's because you
viewed twerking negatively are you a
twerker are you secret
worker that i don't know i just think i
just think there are people that do
things that i probably don't care for
but i respect people's rights to live
and
celebrate and do the things they want to
do on their own tim poole twerker
enthusiast
what if they were what if they were what
if they were dancing what if they were
like polka dance or square dancing or
something still it's just kind of weird
into politics again i'm with you with
the personal freedom stuff
to me is just a little distasteful
culturally
here we go spidgbandersnatch says
tim for an anti-war guy you sure do like
high-tech weapons
yes you see what happens if you have an
active denial system surrounding your
property
there's no conflict there's no war
people leave you alone that simple
i'm all for you know look if if the
beaches of california were stormed by an
enemy invader i'd be like
you know what what do you need me to do
like i'm i'm here people are
i'll fight defensively if you're like
we're going to send people to syria to
remove their dictators think about the
pipeline
i don't know about all that um there are
other reasons of course
but uh look if you have really great
weapons you can stop
all of it and just it's over it's done
there's no war
all right let's just read one one more
super chat purple says
my i am a gorilla shirt has arrived
today and it's actually very comfortable
and the design isn't super tacky oh want
me to tweet it to you
um well i don't tweet it at me because i
just never even clicked the rest
i i don't function on twitter you know
what i mean but you can tweet it at
sourpatch lids
and if you would like to get your own i
am a gorilla t-shirt go to timcast.com
click shop and it is there and it's
actually the most sold shirt we've ever
put together and it's ridiculous
i'm like looking at the numbers i think
we sold over 800 so far
800 i am a gorilla shirts look at luke
with this i'm joe biden and i forgot
this month
my shirt sales went down 75 percent you
son of a gun
yeah i'm like down yeah they went down a
lot but that's okay
i still appreciate all the support and
um you know i gotta eat too so
luke's got these fancy political
messages i'm just selling shirts that's
got a cartoon grill on it
people should realize that hey i think
we need to be more representative of
our ideas i think too many people are
shy about their stances
what better stance can you have than
wearing this shirt in public to
represent
your your kind of larger discontent with
a president who's not really there
yes you could do like this stance
yeah there you go i guess it's a
physical stance smash the like button
because many people haven't smashed the
like button
subscribe share the video if you really
do like it sharing this podcast leave us
a good review on itunes
if you have not checked us out on itunes
or spotify do so and
follow us however that works and uh it's
greatly appreciated but also go to
timcast.com
become a member because that is the
shield in the event we get totally nuked
off the internet
let me tell you something we have
millions of subscribers or
i should say you know my channels have
millions of subscribers i've got
millions of followers
you know everybody here combined we have
a decent amount but if we had
only 10 000 people out of the millions
that were members we'd never have to
worry about censorship again and we'd
actually
that's not even one percent like less
than one percent seriously 10 000 people
as members
and then we can expand we can hire
people we can grow more
and we wouldn't have to worry about
censorship and that crazy that of out of
the millions of people who watch
only ten thousand i think that they will
create that barrier about expanding the
company
a lot of people have been hitting me up
wanting what's happening for us
well we gotta get to that point for this
company we gotta get to that yeah
yeah we'll talk about it often but it it
it requires a lot of strategy and
planning
and and right the organization if we can
build the structure
then we have to find the people the
people are i know a lot of people are
willing and not
it's not about finance just about the
structure like what would they be doing
where
would we be there are podcasts way
smaller than this one
that have 30 to 50 000 people
giving 10 bucks a month and it blows my
mind like there's
these people with these smaller podcasts
and no disrespect because they only have
like 50
000 subscribers but because they're
paying subscribers they're super rich
i wonder why they don't expand their
operations probably because they're rich
and happy
but i want to do more like i want to i
want to get journalists working i want
to get
more content gaming you know fun
exciting stuff so
you know teamcast.com become a member
but uh um
steve yes fortitude ranch you want to
give a shout out mention anything people
should know
um well we uh spots are limited
we constantly expanding so um as
tension rises and problems get more
difficult
we can't always say that there will be
one
available um so if somebody has a mind
to do it it would be a good time
to do it we uh to become a member yes to
become a member
uh we also have fortitude tokens which
actually puts cryptocurrency
yes wow wow really dr miller actually
is a consultant for uh blockchain and
cryptocurrency
this is great we should have went deep
on this whoa whoa
so like is it the currency you use in
the in the at the campsites
no no it's not about that it's for
people to reserve a spot for a
membership
oh wow cash isn't king when
there is you know when things happen
hyperinflation
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh that's really
cool is it um a security
are you familiar with the or is it a
non-fungible token
uh so well it's tradable i mean it's
it's
you know you you can purchase and they
can be traded where can they buy it
it's been gone uh that i can't tell you
because he handles it
it's not so under my so like someone
could trade me the token i could use for
membership
yes where you can buy i mean you can buy
tokens and it holds what happens what
it does is it locks down the price and
it secures a place in line so
once everybody keeps piling in excuse me
if somebody comes next week but you want
to pull the trigger then you get to pull
the trigger
they don't cool cool you're also saying
you're looking for investors right
yeah well to quickly expand it takes
about a million dollars
if if you come out and visit west
virginia you'd see a million dollars
sitting in there
eight inches of reinforced concrete uh
steel and three foot of earth
isn't easy to do and so talking about my
romance language here right
well so in order to expand we'd like to
you know give the ability the
affordability for folks
not to travel so far and open up the
different markets but it will take
investors to do that because
um you know we use the funds for
membership
to uh maintain and expand the current
ranches
they can come and contact you through
the website too
uh manager at fortituderanch.com
they can actually be uh get part of the
business i mean it's uh
and then they become a member right yeah
and they also become a member
cool luke i hear that you have t-shirts
oh yeah yeah
i want to stop being ridiculous with it
i release videos on
we are change i have a separate in the
independent media organization
everything about it and how you could be
involved whether shirts or
other stuff that i do is it's all on we
are change.org forward slash
donate but also give a double follow
to at sourpatch lidge i feel sorry and
bad because i was so excited i totally
forgot to do introductions so
give a double follow to uh lydia there
oh thank you
thank you i appreciate that my at is
sarah patchell it's l-y-d-s on twitter
and
real sour patch lids now on gab and
instagram which i changed to reflect
my gap and then i don't have any
products to sell i'm here to
sustainably grow this organization and
help
thrive which we are on the path to
thriving but you can follow me online at
ian crossland
hit me up on twitter i like to talk
about science and stuff so selfless yeah
and don't forget you can follow me on
twitter instagram and mines
at timcast check out my other youtube
channels youtube.comtimcast
youtube.comcastnews
we're live monday through friday at 8 00
pm so we will be back tomorrow and
tomorrow i imagine is probably going to
be weird
i don't know if it'll be crazy but weird
maybe
just because there's not going to be any
people there so uh who
who's coming tonight jack murphy we
normally don't announce guests but jack
is a regular
you know so so he's he's always here
this is going to be a great conversation
we'll see how things play out
so make sure you come back hang out and
don't forget go to timecast.com become
members
help help us create this base so that we
can expand
and do more and we're going to expand
either way don't get me wrong but i'm
just concerned about what happens if we
get banned
is it over not if we get a core
base of members then we can continue up
until the internet explodes i guess
so thanks for hanging out everybody and
steve thanks again for for coming and
joining us and talking about fortitude
ranch
my pleasure i'm going to be uh looking
into this and
for everybody else we will see you all
tomorrow at 8 pm
you